this is viral video showing white dust
some kind of strange substance falling
onto cars and news reports that in
eastern West Virginia I love saying that
and Maryland people are reporting a
strange substance blanketing their
vehicles and their homes and outside now
of course everybody's very concerned
we're downwind from the uh East
Palestine derailment it it may be a
little late for this to actually be
hitting us now so it could be a dust
storm but West Virginia announced they
don't know the source of the substance
they're going to be testing it hopefully
it's just dust being blown from you know
the Midwest or from Texas but needless
to say there is an investigation people
are concerned and this is exactly what
we had been talking about a week or two
ago and now sure enough what a
coincidence something is happening I
gotta say the idea that dust storm would
be the perfect coincidence considering
we were just talking about one vehicles
that were being covered in a white
substance or residue near East Palestine
now we're seeing that white substance
residue or a similar one in this area
downwind from the disaster and then
they're like oh but there's also a dust
storm and I'm like well it's the perfect
time for a dust storm to happen when
we're concerned about exactly this
so we'll talk about that plus we got a
crazy historic project Veritas seen
another I think a top level resignation
from one of their staff members and
they've put out a video begging people
please we need your support and they
want James O'Keefe back and then we'll
talk about some culture stuff because we
got a funny story was it Angela Davis
that's her name right
uh Black Panther yeah she found out
she's a descendant of the Mayflower yeah
so this is you know is it a black
critical race Theory kind of activist
who's discovering she in fact is
descended from colonizers but the the
story there's actually a bit nuanced and
a lot of people are laughing but we'll
get into all that before we get started
my friends head over to timcast.com
become a member and support our work
click that join us button at timcast.com
you'll get access to our new Live
members only show Monday through
Thursday it goes up around 10 10 p.m
right when we wrap the live show we go
live you can watch that and a lot of
people really do like that we're doing
it live now once the show ends it stays
as a video on demand to be watched
whenever you want in our massive library
of content and today we launched the
first episode of the culture war with
Tim Poole podcast over at youtube.com
timcast and it's all it's also going to
be up on Apple Spotify Etc we uh I
talked with Ali London it's very
interesting next week I'm really excited
we're going to have uh uh and we'll just
say an artist an artist to talk about uh
vax mandates and other things negatively
impacting the industry so it's going to
be a really really fun show so check
that out if you haven't already don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is
former acting Secretary of Defense Chris
C Miller it's kind of interesting
engaging discussion it was already
getting kind of crazy talking about all
the stuff that's going on in the
administration but uh yeah people don't
know this he actually showed up at our
door and knocked and said can I come on
we said Not until you write a book and
so we kicked him out and he came back
with a book we said okay now you can
come on so uh thanks for hanging out
should be fun we also got a lot aliyahu
hanging out hey everybody what's up I am
Ahad aliyahu I'm a field reporter here
at timcast news thanks for having me and
Phil Labonte hello everyone I am Phil
Levante the lead singer of All That
Remains uh anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary
business card that's that's that's
that's how I want to be you don't need a
business card because you are a rock
star that's right that's right I uh
Chris we talked about your book a little
bit before it's uh Soldier secretary is
the name of it and talk about
repurposing the war machine I've been
thinking about a lot about it you
mentioned that's kind of what's in the
book maybe not the entire premise but
really quick can you elevator pitch the
the premise of the book yeah
thanks Ian thanks for the setup that was
awesome Tim you got the best crew in
town I think I think Joe Rogan should be
threatened I know you I know you said
that there's no competition at all yeah
because I got like 500 times the
audience we do hey not tonight when this
gets out uh yeah so the book is really
about a couple things you know only
seven percent of our nation serves uh
right now and they're veterans so 93 of
our population doesn't serve which is a
good problem to have like we're not in
armed Society right I love this what I
found though when I was in government I
was an Army Green Beret for years then I
was in government in the Pentagon I
found there's a seems to be there's a
misunderstanding between those that
serve and those they serve on both sides
so I try to like in an engaging kind of
fashion not one of these you know this
boring DC Memoirs that are like this big
like door stops and you just name check
yourself and you're like I'm not reading
this I wanted to keep this entertaining
and engaging uh so that's kind of the
theme of the book but it's about
accountability because I'm I'm still
just angry that we can lose a war and
nobody's held accountable people get
promoted and they move up in the in the
ranks or they get these big jobs so I'm
kind of still a little still a little
bit angry about that and then finally
yeah I think you know we're spending way
too much money on defense and I think a
lot of that some of that can be uh spent
much better not some of it a lot of it
but spent much better well let's uh
let's let's let's get into it in the
show oh yeah sorry man I didn't mean to
I talked to sorry no not too long you
did what I asked thank you Chris uh and
also I want to introduce Kellen yeah
what's up everybody it's Kellen
um uh surge is doing the culture war
with Tim Poole he's producing that show
on Friday mornings so he's not here on
Friday nights I'll be filling in for now
and then but yeah go and check out the
culture War I wanted to make him work 24
hours straight with no sleep but they
told me that was illegal so I guess
kellen's here all right let's uh let's
jump into the first story and we have
this tweet from raw's alerts Roz alerts
what does that mean I don't know either
way breaking multiple reports of an
unknown white dust particles falling out
of the sky in West Virginia and Maryland
currently multiple multiple people
across West Virginia into Maryland area
reporting an unknown white dust film
descending from the sky some local fire
departments are advising people to shut
their doors and windows and avoid
Outdoors until it can be identified well
let's play the video
there you go look at this
it could just be a dust storm that's
what some people are saying but uh yeah
look at that I don't know about that
maybe it is weird so look at that that's
creepy so it's cocaine bear coming up
this weekend is it some weird is this
some weird that's what people are saying
today I thought that was original they
blanket the Eastern Seaboard and white
dust to promote their movie probably not
a good idea no now rosalert says we
think this is from yesterday's dust
storm that was in parts of New Mexico
Texas Oklahoma as weather satellite
shows large plumes of dust blung across
the states and making its way to the
east coast maybe but I just want to
point out we have this from the West
Virginia this is the what is this uh
depw.gov
the department of what is that the
environment or something environmental
Environmental Protection coordinating
with state and local agencies to
investigate dust issue in the Eastern
Panhandle they receive reports late
Thursday night about the dust and
mobilized inspectors no shelter and
place advisories have been issued in the
area they say that we have staff on site
who are coordinating with our state and
local Partners to identify the material
or any potential causes samples will be
taken they don't know exactly what it is
so a heck of a convenient time for a
dust storm to hit when last week we're
like Hey we're really worried being
downwind from East Palestine when
they're burning all these chemicals
there's videos coming out of Ohio
showing cars blanketed with some kind of
white residue and now we're hearing in
the area downwind from East Palestine
cars are being blanketed in white
residue so it's just bad timing is it
bad timing or uh what do you guys think
well I mentioned uh I think a few days
ago about the half-life of some of the
chemicals that are involved in the
process
um vinyl chloride being one of them 2.3
day Half-Life doesn't mean that they
disappear that half of it disappears
every 2.3 days it just turns into
something else so it could have turned
into there could be other stuff up there
I don't like the hypochondriac lifestyle
of like please be afraid and avoid what
we might be a problem like I there are
scales my friend their scales you can
choose to be a paranoid hypochondriac or
you can choose to plug your ears and act
like nothing's happening exactly trying
to find that balance is the difficult
thing that's why I say look they think
it may be from a dust storm we don't
know and it's heck of bad a heck of a
bad timing for for a dust storm to
happen when we're concerned about these
chemicals I would I imagine that it
might have something to do with the
weather and the only reason that I feel
that way honestly is because yesterday
was almost 80 degrees it was super windy
so the weather's been a little wacky
around here so I think that that might
have something to do with it I really
don't think that that's what I it was 80
yesterday it was 70 78 and it's going
down to 30 tonight yeah so the weather's
been kind a wacky there was a lot of
wind today so I think that that's
probably like not trying to you know be
the the wet blanket but I really think
that it's most likely something but I
don't think I've ever seen a dust storm
before I've never been in a dust bowl
the first part of the the 20th century
there was dust from Iowa making its way
all the way to DC oh okay this is this
is heard of this is yeah Google the Dust
Bowl the historic average for this month
in the Harpers Ferry area is 39 degrees
it was so nice and it was double that
yeah it was it was double the average so
what's the I don't know if they have the
record list down here I'm looking at
like weather weather.com or something I
know it's the boring answer but I I do
think that it's because it was the crazy
weather the record is 73. we must have
broke that because I think it was yeah
we definitely didn't I think we must
have broken the record
huh the Dust Bowl is interesting I'm
reading about it now during the 1930s uh
just a period of severe dust storms
that's how the desert in Maine was
formed uh similar to why the dust ball
uh Dust Bowl was a problem just over
farming or you know crap rotation and
they weren't maintaining topsoil so even
if it is a dust storm of dust blowing
from that doesn't mean that it can't
pick up Vinyl chloride residue and
particles in the atmosphere on the way
fair enough glasses and things like that
you guys hear about there's a bunch of
factories on fire or something like that
it was yeah
no I'm just seeing videos of uh
factories blown up I saw someone talking
today I think it was someone from
um from The Blaze was talking about
Three Fires in oil uh for of the same
oil company and I don't remember the
name of the company I didn't bookmark
the and there's tweets right now I'm
seeing a tweet about uh uranium fire no
in Oak Ridge Tennessee see it's hard
it's it's hard to know you Ben
Three Fires broke out at three different
facilities in Mexico oh yeah yeah I
typed in Ukrainian fire Tennessee and uh
yup Ukrainian it's two days of uranium
uranium uranium you got Ukraine on the
brain ah everybody does man oh man I
mean yeah no Biden's given them more
priority than us yes it's two days ago
there was a uh no injuries or release of
radioactivity after uranium fire at Y-12
in Oak Ridge so Oak Ridge is where you
know the first atomic weapons were built
got to go there when I was acting
Secretary of Defense it was like bucket
list thing the people down there like
the the scientists and the engineers but
that's no joke if they had a fire down
there wow why haven't why haven't we
heard more about that look man I've been
I've been uh maybe it's a little too
paranoid for Ian but if a Cyber attack
was hitting our infrastructure we and we
and the public would not know about it
the government's not going to come out
and be like oh you know that explosion
that happened at that oil refinery yeah
we were attacked by China they're going
to ignore it that unless they need to
Rally support at the time they decide to
get involved in the conflict then
they'll come out and be like yeah we're
being attacked and then it could
actually be a a disaster unrelated to
war and they'll just say it is war you
know what I mean if they could keep the
cat in the bag you know nowadays with
Independent Media and everything
somebody gets a quick little clip on
that of that on their iPhone shoots it
up to Twitter shoots it up to tick tock
or something it goes viral uh yeah
people's like access I think it could
break through because that's my thing is
like it's so hard and you guys do this
every day to break through the kind of
the chaos of the media environment you
think you could break through with a
video of something from uh K-12 or y12
at Oakridge so if I was able to post it
on timcast news uh on Twitter then
definitely but maybe you could tell us a
little bit more about like I don't know
our our the nation's ability to like
censor Us online because if something
like that did happen I'd imagine that
you know they try to suspend Free Speech
or try to keep it on raps not let
reporters report on whatever attack was
going on if they were trying to keep it
you know still I'm with you send it to
Tim cast Charlie Charlie P says the ash
is happening here in PA it is not
weather yeah I I they're burning stuff I
wouldn't be surprised if what they're
burning is making its way down here but
anyway not to not to derail what we're
just talking about I think oh did you
really say derail
ongoing
no did you see that clip from where uh
Pete bootage Edge like had kind of got a
brain crap he said uh sorry I didn't
mean to do he said something did you see
that one there's a train he used a train
and now oh it was so like you know you
know when you're in the zone you you
know and I felt bad for the guy but I
was like oh
he's so bad at this they're all bad at
it's like they shouldn't be in these
positions but you know here we are
it's like that Meme where it's like
wondering how something got there
there's like a car on top of a gate and
then there's like a a dog on a roof and
then you've got like Kamala Harris at
the at the podium or whatever and then
Pete booty judge and he's Palestine I
don't know their ashes here they're
Ashton's Pennsylvania there's even ashes
in East Palestine or maybe that's just
peace Buddha judges presidential
ambitions
I was gonna go with Ash Wednesday too
but that would be a bad really bad pun I
think I I would say that would be too
mean but Matt Walsh has convinced me
otherwise so you know yeah you decided
you you decided you could be mean now
I mean only for goodness well so the
issue is you know talking about this
Matt Walsh thing I'm not saying to you
know scream at somebody and insult him
you know I'm saying be meaner you can't
just be passive and say slow down there
Democrats you've got to actually be like
no stop and we should shame people doing
bad things like degenerate behavior that
harms children should be shamed and
ostracized and shunned from society I
like the word mean in mathematics the
mean is the average so you're really
bringing things back to Center when
you're being mean and a lot of times
that can be like no well reality is this
bill's face right now is hilarious he's
just like has his look like Ian you're
insane in that sense be mean if you're
going to bring if you're going to ground
people in reality but if you're
attempting to make their life worse with
your behavior then that I think
you can't go and just say let's change
what the word is nope nope nope nope
nope stop stop Phil I I I felt the Paul
you felt right you feel right now but I
I gotta go with Ian on this one because
he's basically giving a golden ticket
for everybody to be mean to bad people I
am mean in life directly to your face
what I think what he's saying is if
there's someone who's a really bad
person who's harming kids and you are
mean to them you're actually pulling
them back down to the average by doing
so and I'll take it wood chipper goes
Burr when it comes to pedos but like
when it comes to like actually being
like changing the meaning of words there
you are with that meaning mean what does
that mean I think Ian has you have an
issue with like making puns out of
political arguments
me isn't being nasty that's why they're
different words it's not being cruel
because that's why they're different
words like mean meanness has a I'm
saying I'm sitting here you know being
like all these people are talking to
Matt Walsh saying you shouldn't be mean
to people and blah blah and Matt's like
no there's no limits like we can't let
these people do these bad things and
he's giving you a straight justification
for his action and then Ian gives this
circuitous semantic definition of well
actually mean just replied uh signifies
the average in which case when you're
mean to someone you're just making them
average and it's like okay
they're really causing any physical pain
remember you want to justify calling
someone a creepy degenerate I will not
that I wouldn't yes be what what what
Matt Walsh is talking about is is like
be as cruel as you can like he intends
to be cruel I don't I don't think Matt
Walsh was saying be as cruel as possible
okay maybe not as possible okay he was
just saying be mean to these people like
the these people
I talked about this with Ollie earlier
talked about it last night you've got
people who are doing bad things that
hurt people yes and they either
experience positive reaction or neutral
reaction if there is no negative
response to their actions they'll just
keep doing it because the investment is
clearly in One Direction yeah positive
reinforcement kid that wants to eat
amount of sugar and you're like no you
can't have that now you're being mean
why are you being mean I want it and
you're like you're not gonna have it
sorry that's a good example so that's
maybe mean but if I'm if I'm actually
want to hurt that kid and make that
kid's life worse I'm not that's not the
reason to be mean to him if you want to
make that kid's life worse you give them
more sugar exactly it's like or call him
an idiot you know I could I could I
could insult them too you know you
stupid you don't I'm not trying to
hurt the kid I'm trying to protect him
by being mean it depends if you I think
this is another good analogy for what's
happening in the culture War what's
happening with Society is you've got
people who are gluttonous on social
media in a social sense in that they
will do weird things get a positive
response and then say I will keep doing
this because no one is giving them a
negative response you need to tell
people who are doing bad things what
you're doing is bad and you can do it in
a bunch of different ways you know
calling someone creepy and degenerate is
not the worst possible thing in the
world for a person and it may make them
rethink targeting children and causing
harm to other people and then sometimes
the ends justify the means and in the
case of Matt Walsh it goes bigger than
just that video he released because in
Tennessee he also held a ban on trans
rallies or I'm getting that butchered
but butchered but he in Tennessee they
actually also manage to pass something
in their state legislature Banning
gender transition for people I think
around 14 or 15 you need to fact check
me on that but you know he's actually
accomplishing things and I think it's
like called culture jamming so Matt
Walsh is doing a good job drawing
attention to this even if he is being a
little bit mean you know he's actually
getting things done in Tennessee he's
literally the one to talk think about
using anger in like just the whole he
wasn't decided Well I'm thinking about
using it in like like Jimmy doors like
you got to get mad you got to get out on
the street and block traffic you need to
be the disruption and like feel like in
the 70s when they were protesting the
Vietnam War they were angry they were
pissed because kids their friends were
getting drafted and blown apart and they
were like fear of being sucked into this
stupid War
um so I understand that maybe getting
angry there is some value to it I just I
see it get out of control really quick a
lot of times especially in conversation
so I don't know what do you what do you
think Chris I mean you've been doing
this a long time I love it I love the
conversation yesterday on that and I
guess
I think we do need to get it's about
accountability I think in a lot of ways
is what you're talking about is by being
mean you're driving accountability into
the system no yeah I mean I I call it
accountability call it whatever you want
that the math is simple if someone goes
on Instagram and throws a pie at a
stranger and Instagram gives him money
and all the users say hey that was
really funny you're amazing he's gonna
go wow people really like what I do this
they're gonna keep doing it we saw this
with prank videos on YouTube there were
videos that were getting increasingly
dangerous and insane it starts with one
guy I'm gonna do a prank and he goes you
know he like jumps out from behind the
building and then they're like ah you
scared me you silly goose and then he
gets a million views
three months later the dude's wearing uh
Freddy Krueger mask and drawing a knife
and Swinging it at people I'm
exaggerating but you actually had a
trend on YouTube where people would walk
into black neighborhoods and throw
racial slurs at black people because it
got traffic on YouTube there there was
no negative reaction to the things they
were doing finally YouTube was like
we're going to start Banning content
that does this and apply a negative
pressure that's I don't necessarily
agree I actually kind of agree to a
certain extent with this if people were
doing things that were like expressing
an opinion or being silenced for it it's
one thing if you're literally trying to
cause fights and that's what they were
doing they would walk up to or some
minority say a slur to them and then get
beaten up and they were making they were
getting millions of views on this stuff
it's like bum fights it's like I got my
limits on on you know what should be
promoted and and be given a positive
response to what ends up happening is
there needs to be it used to be
journalists they'd be like hey this is a
bad thing and we're going to show you
and then everyone would be like shun the
bad person shun them now we're in this
this era of total acceptance so people
go on Instagram people go on Twitter
Tick Tock YouTube and they'll do
something genuinely bad and harmful but
now they're getting protected by big
Tech they're going on and telling
children to harm themselves and they're
getting protected and then Matt Walsh
comes out and says you are Eerie you are
creepy you you are no one will find you
attractive and he didn't say it he
didn't say it screaming he wasn't
spitting he's very calmly saying this is
the reality this is the truth
you need to have that
so that the people who are doing the bad
thing say you know what maybe I
shouldn't do this I'll give you an
example he was talking about Dylan
Mulvaney Dylan Mulvaney has videos where
he's giving tampon he's talking about
taking tampons and using them and other
things like this
Dylan Mulvaney did not care that people
on the right were critical of it it was
only when leftists got critical and said
what you are doing is creepy did Dylan
Mulvaney come out and be like I'm sorry
I was just trying up the negative
reaction worked in stopping a person
from doing a bad thing that hurt people
so you don't need to go and do anything
crazy you just need to say outright like
I don't like you I think you're bad I
think you're unattractive I think you're
an evil person
tell them why they're bad don't let them
just don't tolerate bad behavior that's
hurting people absolutely and I wanted
to clarify on the bill in Tennessee that
Matt Walsh helped drum up support for it
says Tennessee House Republicans on
Thursday overwhelmingly passed the ban
on gender transition health care for
minors the bill prohibits children from
receiving puberty blockers hormone
therapies or surgical procedures people
who received the treatments as minors
would also be able to sue parents
Guardians and physicians for authorizing
the care under a statute of limitations
wow so you think daily wire being being
in Tennessee has anything to do with
that well he had Matt Walsh had a rally
there
um that helped drum up a lot of support
for this and he lobbied for this as well
and definitely I think it has something
yeah absolutely I mean what is a woman
as a documentary was tremendous it
pushed the the story Into the mainstream
it was all I everybody had talked about
it was watching it Joe Rogan comes out
he's like you see this thing this is
crazy a lot of people did not know what
they're doing and they're still doing
and they're they're expanding on you
know so one of the biggest things about
protecting like not letting people do
harm to children and they're like you
can't put kids on puberty blockers when
they're 11 because that's gonna hurt
them in the long run you can't cut
people children's penises off because
that's going to hurt them in the long
run but then I've heard from other
people are like if they don't get the
chemical castration they need then
you're they're going to kill themselves
and you're doing harm to them if they
don't get their penis cut off then then
you're doing harm to them because they
they don't feel right and it's like how
is that how did those realities it's not
real because there's evil eye yeah
there's a lie like it's it's a
definitely a warped it's a warped way of
looking I think it's a warped way
because it didn't use people I'd never
heard people talk like that before so
yeah some sort of it's it's like Donald
Trump gets on the phone with the
president of Ukraine and he's like
what's this video that's going around
where Biden's trying to withhold money
or something can you look into that and
then the establishment machine comes out
and says Donald Trump engaged in a quid
pro quo and so that now he's going to be
impeached and it's like it was it was
Joe Biden who did that not Donald Trump
they project what like they accuse
everyone of of doing what they are
literally doing that's it so when
they're when they're targeting children
and putting them in situations that
could result in death and suicide and
self-harm they accuse everyone else of
doing it but you take a look at what's
going on with the transitioners and
there's more and more every single day
we I was talking with Ali London about
how on Reddit there's 50 000 members of
the D transition subreddit horror
stories of saying like I was tricked
into this I was rushed into this I think
Chloe Cole is now suing Kaiser
Permanente yeah so when these people
come out and say no we have to otherwise
the children will be harmed it's like
I'm pretty sure amputating the genitals
of a child will not save their life but
probably cause them to self-harm in the
future that's just common sense Chris I
know we're seeing a lot of this um
transgenderism and lgbtq ideology
infiltrate a lot of different parts of
our government and Society I know you
were a former Secretary of Defense can
you tell me and you also served in
Afghanistan did you see any of that in
the Army and what are what have been the
current policies towards it do you think
they should be different specifically
General Millie
she set me up for that no no I didn't
hey you know I did I did oh gosh 30
something years in in the military and
this this might sound cliche but it's
it's not it's true I never met a single
person that joined the military to fight
the culture wars right the military is
the ultimate meritocracy work hard
you'll get promoted you'll have
opportunities
and so people joined to prepare to fight
real wars so I have great hope and I
know you guys get a little down once in
a while like you know this is Ancient
Rome or something
but I'll tell you what the sergeants the
ones that are responsible for like four
soldiers Sailors Airmen Marine space
force Guardians
they they're focused on making sure
their people are ready to go to war and
I had I went down to uh Special Forces
Group recently because I thought maybe
I'm at it maybe I'm out of sorts you
know I'm old now I've been out of the
military for a few years and went down
there just to get kind of do a
temperature check check on the sergeants
that run the Army and I'm like okay they
still got the right Focus the problem I
think is that they're confused because
their leadership is getting involved in
the culture wars and they're like if I
get involved in the culture wars I get
fired and what you know so I think
there's a confusion there's a loss of
confidence between those that are down
there doing the everyday work leading
soldiers and their bosses who are saying
there's that same uh do as I say not as
I do that doesn't work in the military
you got to be you got to be coherent
across so uh I'm worried yes but I'm
also enormously enormously confident in
you know our young leaders these kids
are 21 22 years old and they're
responsible for four or five other
people's lives they take that pretty
seriously so uh I'm not worried about
that I'm worried about the fact that dog
like yeah senior leadership's getting
involved in things that they shouldn't
get involved they need to focus on war
fighting and combat effect I was
thinking like if something were to
happen tragic in the United States was
sucked into a war for real like the
balloon floated over the United States
for five days or whatever like that I
would hope the military is ready to step
in and take control if Biden can't do
his job which he seems like he's not
able to do his job I don't want to not
have faith in the God no but I don't
have faith in him you don't want the
military to take over I want if if uh I
want if there's a commander that is
incapable of commanding he needs to be
relieved of Duty that's what we have the
vice president and the Speaker of the
House for there is a there is a line of
people that
if the president can't do his job you do
not want the military to assume power if
when you can have when we have the the
whole Constitution has got like all this
stuff handled I don't care about the
constitution in reality if we were under
threat of death I don't want Joe Biden
in control of the military or Kamala
Harris Chris so I know that trans
soldiers um they could currently openly
serve right now in the Army and the
perfect force will provide hormone
therapy and mental health care do you
think that's in within the purview of
what they should be happening in the
army a America I'm gonna I'm gonna uh
I'll tap dance on that one a little bit
first off Phil preach it it's all about
civilian control yes and the last thing
we ever want thank you
it's a military officer to think and
that that's part of my book is that I'm
concerned that the military the off
senior officers are getting too
big-headed about this and thinking like
yeah if there's a problem we'll step in
because there were rumors about that
remember with President Trump that the
senior military leadership was like we
think this guy's crazy the Third on
January 6th the third in line to the
Office of the President asked the head
of the Joint Chiefs and staffs hey can
we just have the military room
serve the machine guns Nancy Pelosi
requested a military crew a military
coup on January 6th like that actually
happened she went to million asked him
and then it blows my mind she called and
said can they intervene and stop Trump
try to engage in any kind of military
activity he said ma'am that would be a
coup against a sitting president she
tried yeah I get the civilian leadership
I mean like like obviously we need
civilian leadership because you don't
want a Jew into taking control like a
military government but if you have
incompetent leadership do we just wait
and hope that the next civilian is going
to do it right like do we just sit and
wait what guarantee what makes you think
that just because the person that would
assume control from the military is is
somehow not is somehow competent just
because they're in the military I don't
know I just know that Joe Biden's not in
my opinion fair but that doesn't mean
like that doesn't mean you throw the
Constitution away or you throw or just
go ahead and throw all the laws away
well Joe Biden you know he's got tapioca
for brain so we got to go ahead and get
a a general to kick to run the show that
is a terrible terrible idea I feel what
you're saying concerned about Joe Biden
I get it because I feel it too Joe Biden
I I genuinely believe he's got cognitive
problems but but just because of that is
not or that is not a justification to
have him removed from office with guns
like that is that is third world country
that is Banana Republic stuff that is
like going to war kind of stuff you that
is not what we need now that is like
going to work kind of stuff like I'm
saying if we are declared war upon and
we have now we're in it there are
Chinese troops in Alaska moving down
like do we just wait for Biden to wake
up do we wait for Kamala Harris to take
control what do we do let's ask the
expert who is currently sitting across
from from us
what do you do in the event uh let's say
the U.S gets invaded that's it how about
let's let's make let's let's wheel
things back Chinese spy balloon comes
over the U.S potentially tracking data
on our nuclear sites potentially
tracking data on the the sensors that
it's picking up what's coming at it so
the things that we are using to detect
it it is actually detecting let's say
that's a precursor to a move on Taiwan
let's say before the move on Taiwan
we've already seen China go into
territorial Waters around Alaska and
Hawaii let's say they start positioning
the military strike on Taiwan and then
instantly we get a a battalion of
Chinese troops pair dropping or crashing
on the shores of Alaska or something do
we just sit here and go oh Biden's got
it handled
um you're flash I'm flashing back to Red
Dawn come on I've been remade right I
didn't see the second one in the in the
event a true conflict reaches the shores
of the United States do we just sit back
and say Biden is our president and we're
gonna he's got it I still have faith the
system will work in regards to like
that's not something you can ignore
right so and this is kind of comes back
a little bit
like so you've got
uh secretary Austin he's the Secretary
of Defense you have Mark milley you can
say what you want General milley's the
chairman The Joint Chiefs of Staff they
will go to the president and say this is
what has to be done
you know there now the question is
what's their guidance going to be but at
the end of the day you know that's like
an act of War so we are gonna we're
gonna go to war over that if we've got
now you could art let's talk about that
spy balloon was that an act of war that
it violated our airspace well we let it
right we go on all day about that uh so
the go ahead I think the issue is Millie
and uh whoever else they're gonna go to
Biden and go Mr President we have
currently an incursion into U.S soil in
Alaska by a Chinese unit we need to act
now and Biden's going to be like so
deploy the troops to to Libya and he's
going to be like sir you'll hurt me get
it done and okay do they say no I won't
file that order you meant to say Alaska
that's exactly the my concern is
your last resort when you're in those
positions if your boss in this case the
President says something wacky is you
resign and you go public and we don't do
that anymore right so that's the concern
is everybody's in lockstep right now
because they want to get promoted or
they whatever and that's that's exactly
the issue that concerns me is who's
who's quit let's let's talk about the
Spy balloon
who who quit who offered their
resignation over that that was a gross
failure right that was a gross failure
shouldn't somebody been fired they won't
even admit that it was a gross failure
but but shouldn't in the military
someone should have come forward and
said I was responsible for the the
defense of our airspace it was violated
I failed I am quitting I'm resigning
because I failed to do my job nobody's
come forward to do that so that's that's
my concern is we don't have that ethos
now that that's essential to the officer
Corps that's that's why I brought this
whole conversation up because like
where's the leadership but I can see
like the end of the Roman Republic
Julius Caesar came with the military and
took control military dictatorship
Empire I don't want that but that's what
where my mind is focused with a lack of
leadership you know what the hell's been
happening last month but there's Biden
on East Ohio like I want to I want to
say this I'm wondering
we talk about morals and ethics and uh
often it's not black and white there is
there's a gradient to what degree do we
accept censorship or oppose Free Speech
uh even people who say they claim to be
free speech absolutists I'm like you got
a limit if somebody is posting videos of
child exploitation you're probably going
to come be like okay yeah that's that's
not speech that's illegal it's like well
it's not and and that means you don't
agree you don't believe that anyone can
just say or produce anything they want
there are certain things that are
illegal and then even in so far as what
if you're not a producer of it you're
sharing it for some reason to express an
idea no still no you can't do that stuff
so we accept that there are limits in
this regard
I wonder about I kind of lost my train
of thought what were you just talking
about we're talking about basically when
is it appropriate to resign the ethics
of you know a leadership and whose
accountability I thought was kind of
where we were going with this I'm with I
got you about Caesar
that was my biggest concern right
January 6th there was this narrative I
got it back I got it back okay I got it
back go yeah so my my shoe is basically
we obviously don't like say like
Cambodia in the Kama Rouge The Killing
Fields whatever we see what happens when
brutal merciless dictatorships take over
the Soviet Union but I wonder if the
reason there's such a Negative view of
things like the Roman Empire is because
the people who were in those countries
who wrote down the stories of what
happened were the fat gluttonous
degenerates who were shocked to find
that a country was actually trying to
have some morals again what I mean to
say is it's not black and white there's
certainly circumstances where we're like
okay we got a problem with this
dictatorship and I'm sure there are
circumstances where you get a more
classically liberal but community-based
Stern attitude of service guarantee
citizenship that is to say a government
that doesn't come to you and lock you in
a gulag and mercilessly beat you a
government that comes and says I'm sorry
we are not going to pay your health care
because you're a glutton and you're
eating too much food you need to stop
well the gluttons that generates are
gonna freak out they're gonna write
every story in the world about how the
fascists are taking over and we're
watching this happen so if I saw
something
that was like service guarantee
citizenship if you want to vote you have
to provide some kind of community
service not military maybe it's picking
up trash the left is going to scream
fascism Fascism and I'm kind of like
doesn't that just mean personal
responsibility no one's telling you
you're going to prison no one's going to
beat you can still speak you still play
video games you can still eat all the
ho-hos and Ding Dongs in the world but
we're saying you've got to be
responsible to the community around you
they would call that fascism so in the
event we did have a quote unquote
military takeover but I'm saying that
you know somewhat tongue-in-cheek I mean
quite literally if they came out and
said hey there's a minimum standard and
it's going to be this but you'll be able
to live your lives as you see fit the
people who are going to write the
history books are going to claim a
military dictatorship destroyed freedom
in this country when in reality it might
actually just be something like hey
we're about to collapse the country is
going to fall apart the economy is
spiraling out of control there's riots
in the street I'll give you a better
example if Donald Trump deployed the
military invoking the Insurrection act
during the summer of Love saving 30 plus
lives they would write down in the
history books a military dictator Donald
Trump suppressed free speech so I I
question these narratives throughout
history some of them are probably bad
some of them might not been might not
have been as as bad
the most recent um at least supposed
coup that almost tried to happen in our
country was supposed to be January 6th
um Chris you were um acting Secretary of
Defense at this time sixth in line for
the presidency so if some clue happened
I think it's sixth in line can somebody
fact check me out I believe it's six I
didn't that's um could you tell me a
little bit more about not your role in
January 6th but our reaction to it as I
understand with the National Guard
careful with your phrasing there uh you
know and then also we were talking about
people resigning there were a lot of
people who resigned from the Trump
Administration following this yeah
Sunshine soldiers for you know uh
you brought up if we would have since uh
soldiers up on Capitol Hill
on January 6 the morning of Jan so let's
go back I hate to do this let's go back
I'm going to be pedantic and talk about
our high school civics class Capitol
Hill legislative branch military
executive branch
Capitol Hill you don't go up there if
you're the executive branch of the
military unless you're invited to do
something different is called a military
coup so I was not going to be party to
that obviously because that's
Un-American in violation of my oath of
office to the Constitution so this
narrative that we should have moved
faster or had been up there beforehand
would have been could you imagine what
what would have happened if we would
have pushed if I would have pushed
National Guard troops up on Capitol Hill
before the riots started wow it would
have been a mess I know the only person
who got killed was Ashley Babbitt by
Capitol Police Officer Michael bird
that was the only shot fired do you
think that was a justifiable shot given
the situation well you know the
Protective Service detail I I don't it
it appears to me that when she came
through the window that she by that she
crashed in on the security bubble and
they and and uh they shot her that was
the moment when I realized we had been
promised that the police in Washington
DC and on Capitol Hill could handle up
to a million protesters that day and you
don't use your military for domestic law
enforcement cop that's what we have cops
for you don't use military you don't use
soldiers to do domestic law enforcement
until Civil Society is broken down like
a natural disaster in New Orleans
everything's gone to you know what
that's when you go in there that's when
the military serves and does uh law
enforcement duties until that happens
keep the military out the military you
talked about Vietnam military really
violated time tons of American civil
liberties by spying on Americans these
are the things that are still doing it
yeah my last follow-up was going to be
many people in the Trump Administration
decided to resign as a result of January
6th and the events following it you
chose not to can you tell me a little
bit more about that decision yeah
because I wanted to get more facts so
you know I had been in combat a day or
two I'd been a leader in the military
commander in the military and you don't
you got to be stable You Got to Be
steady right that's what good leaders do
I saw a lot of those political figures
that bailed that day doing it for
political reasons I was like we need to
find out what happened we're still
finding out what happened that day so
you know here's the one that always bugs
me when these bigwigs talk about well
you know I thought it would have been
the reason I stayed is because I had to
protect something I if it wasn't for me
you know I had to protect our soldiers
I'm not saying that that's not what I'm
saying I'm just saying I that's my job
I'm gonna I got six weeks left or
whatever it was four weeks left and you
know what was that was it Thomas Paine
Sunshine soldiers what's that
yeah you know it's like hey you get paid
for the good times and the bad and you
really get paid for the tough times
that's what the American people pay for
right you never thought it was a coup or
anything
dude I was running the military there
was no coup okay because nobody was
right about that Millie's like you know
the only way there has to come through
us there was going to be no military
coup I dude I I spent my life in service
to this country and I swore to protect
and defend the Constitution there's no
way that I was going to allow back to
your point about resigning if it came
down to that and the president was not
about he wasn't going there if it would
have gone there I would have resigned
and gone right outside and gotten on TV
and said I resigned in protest because I
was asked to do something uh
anti-constitutional period end of story
by him that's if he asked for you to
bring troops out if if he no if he want
if he was going to use them
inappropriately or anti-constitutionally
what about the uh oh I forgot the date
was it May 29th when was the what was
the Insurrection yeah May 29th what
about that
um you had these these uh far left as
setting fire to the to St John's Church
they set fire to a guard post the White
House they tore down barricades and the
response was police you know police came
out did their their normal thing I
suppose it's probably the appropriate
response
there were National Guard there that was
one remember you don't recall the the
national guard for the helicopters down
the middle of the streets uh that
evening oh gosh yeah there was uh a lot
went on that's not appropriate use of uh
the military I don't think so
no that's what you have local law
enforcement for that what about when
they're not doing their jobs I mean in
Seattle and Portland we saw what was it
120 some odd days even New York they
were fire overwhelmed Federal buildings
for a hundred days father of extremists
were throwing fire bombs and explosives
like at that point shouldn't the Federal
Government Act to defend its territory
like it's building and like the people
who live and work in the area federal
government did they that put in they
didn't they put in huge numbers of
federal law enforcement to protect
Federal property the issue was the mayor
was on the left this side of the
spectrum and was allowing that to happen
it was a debacle and you've been out to
Portland lately oh my gosh but where but
all that really happened was federal law
enforcement stood inside the building
and then the leftists continued to
firebomb it for 100 plus days until they
got bored with it and stopped the the
feds did not actually come out feds were
all over that town don't you remember
the crisis that happened when uh how did
it go on for 120 days like why why did
it not stop I I believe in local
government I don't believe the federals
federal law enforcement should come in
without uh absolutely can protect
Federal property but the governor has
his National Guard his or her they had
plenty of access to uh security forces
and law enforcement and National Guard
without calling in the federal troops if
the federal government can't stop people
for three or four months from throwing
firebombs at its building then they
should probably just leave they
shouldn't be there because they're
completely impotent I I like the I know
they were there they did The Joint unit
they had DHS they had ice they had a
bunch of CBP or whatever we've been
coming and they could do nothing to stop
foreign
the city and firebombing their building
you can't do it you shouldn't be there
it was like they sent troops into a
Siege and then they just had to sit
there and be sieged for what was the
point it's better than having no troops
in The Siege I mean I get it but I think
if someone commits a crime against the
federal government the federal
government has a right to arrest
criminals but hey look man I guess I can
just I'll side with my libertarian
friends on this one and be like the end
result of this in my mind The Logical
conclusion is
it's a waste of taxpayer dollars to have
federal law enforcement be paid to stand
around for four months while people
firebomb a building and they can't do
anything about it so how about we just
save ourselves the money let the far
left keep running amok and doing
whatever they want because clearly we're
not stopping it if Portland and Seattle
want that behavior then far be it you're
right federal government don't be there
shut the building down leave what's the
what's the point of having a courthouse
for the federal government if they're
not going to arrest and convict these
people anyway waste of time case study
of what we're seeing now the interesting
thing in Portland I was out there a
couple months ago is local business is
now in Rebellion comes back to economics
right why wouldn't they they are clean
in that town there's been a sea change
out there with their attitude but it was
a case study of things just going out of
control I'm with you yeah what happens
if a governor requests Federal uh troops
do they then owe the federal government
something so like we'll pay you back
later kind of thing or is it just they
come and they serve for free no
questions asked there are loopholes
technically speaking there's some law
that you have to pay you know some but
usually it all gets waived so if the
governor would have asked for federal
troops well first off we would have said
have you expended all your you know 5
000 members of your National Guard that
work for you
it's like I have and I still have not
gained control of City XYZ and then yeah
federal troops would have been brought
in with support when um the George Floyd
riots happened I think it was day two I
walked into the living room where Tim
was I was like why have we not sitting
in the National Guard what's happening
why fires why uh same thing like the
feds did not want to get involved
because it was a State National Guard
did go in the Federal National Guard did
go in no uh DC National Guard but the
Summer of Love was all over the country
yeah we saw we saw riding in towns
people have never heard of for somehow
and there's crazy videos there's videos
of like antifa far leftists walking
through some kind of like Suburban
neighborhood and a bunch of young men
who live in the areas came out and then
countered them and chased them off but
we had we we had this report from
Michael Tracy of these small towns in
the midwest where stores were ransacked
windows were smashed and it was by BLM
and antifa and they're like putting up
board spray painting small business
please don't hurt us and things like
that
and Tom Cotton wrote send to the Troops
the New York Times went to revolt and
Donald Trump said nah nah nah just let
let the country be destroyed by far left
extremists but every Governor has their
National Guards citizen soldiers one
weekend a month they're part of their
National Guard that they control and
they didn't do anything well how's that
the federal government's problem I mean
if the federal government can't do
anything about National widespread far
left terrorism then I will just revert
back to the whole National divorce Civil
War conversation because at this point
it's kind of like the federal government
can do one thing it can steal money from
your paycheck and then burn it in
Ukraine Meanwhile we're being our
businesses are being set on fire and
we're having far left extremists up to
our libraries we're having adult sex
performers performed for children but I
can rest assured that local government
will do nothing and the federal
government will take money from my
paycheck and my business and burn it in
Ukraine I think it's about arm yourself
locally I don't want vigilante justice
but like if your Governor won't do it
and your president won't do it and
people are getting killed outside your
house like what what are people supposed
to do in that situation I've never seen
that in my life God forbid it would ever
happen but like just local militia is
that actually constitutionally legal if
the governor won't step up absolutely
I mean you can't go and kill someone
like you can't like have a posse go just
shoot someone but like you there are
places that have uh citizen arrests and
stuff like that and yeah look at look at
Georgia look at uh look at the uh the
McMichaels when a guy is
a felony burglary suspect on camera
committing felony burglary and the
police go door to door and say this is
the guy committing the felony Burgers
burglars of the past several months in
your neighborhood and then this guy is
reported running down the street if you
pursue him and he tries to steal your
shotgun and gets shot in the in in the
in in the conflict you will go to prison
for the rest of your life if you are in
Wisconsin and a group of BLM extremists
who have already set fire to a building
twice if they show up to your house and
you brandish a shotgun the cops will
come and arrest you if you're in
Portland and far left extremists create
an autonomous Zone where they kill
people are mostly in Seattle where the
people were killed the police will do
nothing the federal government will do
nothing but rest assured if you as an
American citizen defend yourself from
these people they will show up to your
doorsteps and mercilessly beat you if
you protest at the government if you
haphazardly Bumble down the street in DC
see where the cops opened the door to
the Capitol Building for you and say
come on in I don't agree with it but I
respect it you will find yourself in
solitary confinement for two years
without charges where is the love lie
where is the LIE there is nothing lie
there is no lie It's Working Class
People who are desperately trying to
follow the rules are being told for the
past several years will take your money
and leave you high and dry when the
Psychopaths burn your house down and
they're doing it in Georgia these
extremists who are protesting in the
forest burning houses down flipping
trucks over and shooting at cops we are
being told over and over and over again
by local government we will do nothing
for you we're scared of them we're being
told by the federal government we will
do nothing for you but rest assured I'll
say it again they'll take our money and
burn it in Ukraine speaking of burning
money in Ukraine Chris I think you said
that you wanted to reduced or we could
reduce the military budget by something
like 40 or 50 percent what do you think
about the United States reaction to um
Russia invading Ukraine and what would
you have done a real interview it
happened if it does what would what
would your reaction of Ben had the
invasion happened under your watch I
don't like bullies end of story I I just
authoritarian totalitarian doesn't work
for me uh and you know the big
difference here in Ukraine then we had
Vernon taking our money and literally
throwing it into the fire in Iraq and
Afghanistan was and when we left all
that money two you know how you know
what we were spending a week in Iraq and
Afghanistan two billion dollars a week
and the whole thing came undone as soon
as we left Ukraine uh they're willing to
fight they're willing to die they're
willing to have their infrastructure
destroyed so uh I believe that having
supporting Ukrainian
forces is in our best interest however
I got I got one for you I got one for
you I like let's go ahead if it's so
important take that out of the dod
budget as opposed to just adding to the
federal deficit so I would I'm wondering
if there would be such eagerness to
provide Exquisite weapon systems to the
ukrainians if that money was being
subtracted from the 858 billion dollars
that we spend on defense each year if I
could get specific so
um as I understand we've sent more money
to Ukraine right now than the entirety
of the Afghanistan War I know we just
reached to the point in sending tanks
where I know at the beginning of the
conflict about a year ago that wasn't
even in consideration how far do you
think we should go with weapons should
we send more tanks potentially should we
send aircraft
right so here's here's my problem is
the nature of warfare is changing right
tanks and planes aren't the answer we're
doing the wrong thing we're trying to
rebuild we're trying to build them an
image of our military that we have lost
every war that we have fought since
World War II I think Korea is going to
go in the I think Korea is going to go
in the win column someday I'd actually
put Korean in the win column now uh so
my issue is like send in all these
Exquisite wicked expensive tanks what's
a tank run for uh let's call it two
let's use an aircraft aircraft goes for
about 120 million dollars a piece drones
can go for what's a DGI uh the Chinese
DGI goes for 2000. 2000 a piece I'm not
going to do public math but you guys
have your computers 100 million divided
by two thousand so
I let's go ahead instead of giving like
80 000. that's a lot can you imagine if
you're sitting there you're a Russian
and you're like okay I've got my Radars
up I see one plane coming I'm good I can
handle that because I got a bunch of
missiles can you imagine all of a sudden
when your radar screen just goes all
white and 20 000 drones are coming in on
you we're fighting the wrong way that's
my concern so we're sending all this
money that it's the wrong capability
they can create light shows with drones
that take the shape of a human face and
have it animate and look around and then
a hand comes out and like waves all the
drones just make the lights I love those
it's amazing imagine if they did that
but like had them fly in a scatter
formation carrying kilograms of you know
explosive material or something and then
Wars that the things you can do with
drones and explosives they can they can
action open up a computer
choose every single Target for twenty
thousand drones and then every drone
just targets
Windows apartment buildings cars I agree
I think we're we're fighting an old
school kind of way that's crazy isn't it
a little bit contradictory though if you
want to reduce spending by 40 50 but you
still want to send more arms to Ukraine
so that's that's the that's the thing
I'm trying to argue in my book is we can
reduce spending if we rethink how we do
our military operations instead of a 14
billion dollar aircraft carrier that's
14 billion dollars instead of 1.5
trillion for the F-35 fighter we that's
all Cold War stuff it's not going to
last in a high intensity where it's
going to last 72 hours we need to
rethink how we do this we need to go
cyber we need to go machine learning
artificial intelligence you want better
spending but straight into straight into
a AI autonomy oh okay because what Tim
said was you can you can this isn't like
some Skynet thing or anything that's not
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
being able to go a human in the loop but
going okay we have
500 targets and then you can program
your stuff to go get them without having
to have enough heat seeking yeah yeah so
you can say like these are the
parameters of what we Target and so my
big thing is return we've got one
million people in uniform active duty
show up every day right
we have one million in the National
Guard and Army Reserve that's one
weekend a month two weeks during the
year and then we have about 700 000
civilians 700 000 civilians work for the
Department of Defense my point is we can
cut a huge amount of the active duty for
us I want to go back to the Citizen
Soldier that's what I want I want to go
back to the Citizen Soldier who lives in
his community and you we taught you guys
were talking about social unrest and
everything I want that Community to have
their soldiers
next to them living there and we don't
have that as much anymore so that's
that's fine I want to ask a question uh
someone is in the Super Chat asked this
do you think that the U.S provoked
Russia through its operations in Ukraine
I think what provoked Russia was our
failure to withdraw effectively from
Afghanistan and we were so feckless and
it was such that's not to criticize
anybody that was on the ground doing the
work that's not what I'm criticizing but
the the failure that was a debacle and I
think Putin looked at that I think when
they opened up the pilot Bureau archives
in like 50 years and they look at their
National Security Council notes they're
going to go like wow Putin saw that as
weakness in the United States and saw
that as a green light to go after we saw
it we saw it in Taiwan why why did
Russia go into Ukraine
I have no idea I think I know I think
they want Sebastopol as a trade Port
when the Soviet Union broke up they took
it and they gave Black Sea access like
Mediterranean access to Ukraine they
want to keep Russia from becoming a
global economic hegemon but now he's
trying to take Sebastopol on the
freeways East uh 97 and 105 that go down
in there I watched the morning shows you
know where they had all the retired
generals the Barry McCaffrey and Admiral
stavaritus and all these guys who used
to watch that all the time right man and
you remember last year at this time
they're like key will fall in 72 hours
and then of course today they're like oh
the Freedom Fighters of Ukraine the
reason I bring this up is anybody that
predicts what's going to happen over
there I have no confidence I agree I
think everything we've been told from
everybody you know it's just even been
wrong about what what the directory of
the war is going to be do you think it
would be I think I think uh Russia
obviously has its interests with Ukraine
so it's not fair to completely blame the
U.S operations for provoking Russia
Russia wanted like like he was saying
Sebastopol Crimea sure Don bass region
regardless of what the U.S was doing
what ultimately happens is I think
Vladimir Putin laments the fact that
they lost Ukraine with the fall of the
Soviet Union they want access they have
operations in Crimea and then both the
U.S and Russia aren't engaged are
engaged in influence operations in
Ukraine in an attempt to win the favor
of Ukrainian people but it seemed like
for the most part majority of the
country was moving towards NATO and the
EU even when I went there that's what I
saw the people in in Kiev were like we
want access to Europe Europe was wealth
for these people they said if we get
Schengen Zone if Ukraine becomes a part
of the Schengen Zone and we can freely
travel and work our standard of living
is going to Skyrocket our wealth will
Skyrocket Russia's offer with the
Federal Trade union was not that
appealing to them of course you get the
ousting of yanakovich U.S involvement to
whatever degree you've got Joe Biden
barisma energy operations competing with
Russia both the U.S NATO Russia have
heavy interests Russia moved in because
the U.S was winning the conflict there
was a cold war with Ukraine before there
was a hot War Russia turned it hot
because the U.S was winning it well they
annexed Crimea which was potentially
could have went hot but they didn't they
just let it happen and then because of
that that's the influence the the
annexation of Crimea was the line
between cold and hot they brought in
military into the region there was not a
lot of fighting but they took that land
then it went hot in the donbass region
Donald Trump gets elected everything
kind of simmers a little bit down do you
think if we would have reacted
differently to this seizure of Crimea in
that this situation would be different
uh in what way what do you mean because
Obama we didn't do we didn't do Jack we
let him take and then and you know maybe
we were too concerned about something I
don't know the U.S should have declared
a no-fly zone well so there's a couple
ways I look at this first my my
principal morals are if they cannot
justify to me and the American people
why we should be spending money and
being involved in Ukraine it shouldn't
happen in the first place strategically
Obama should have declared a no-fly zone
instantly over the donbass region and
Ukraine which ukrainians would have
supported outright and that would have
prevented Russia from aggressing in the
first place because that would be a
direct Act of war against the United
States when it came to their build up on
the border a year a year ago before The
Invasion I and many other people were
like the U.S strategically should have
declared a no-fly zone before Russia
invaded because then Russians Russia's
move would have been an act of
aggression against the U.S putting them
in a very difficult position instead we
have a Biden who sits on his hands and
does nothing and the military apparatus
around him Russia moves in and now our
hands are tied now we're sinking money
into a toilet and it's just I like you
were saying what more money than
Afghanistan yeah so I saw 20 years of
Afghanistan in 20 years of Vietnam even
crystal ball was talking about this it
is a strategic nightmare so this is a
component of why I'm like we should not
be in this conflict we should have
nothing to do with it we have I mean Ian
we surrender Afghanistan it's a it's a
disaster you mentioned Putin sees this
and he's like wow now's my opportunity
it has been just look man you know
everybody knows I've been playing poker
recently you get a bad hand you fold if
you don't and and the most important
lesson you can learn is if you're if if
you're the eighth best player in the
world and you're at a table with the
seven other best players in the world
you're the sucker get out the US should
have seen everything that was going on
and been like you know we're really bad
at this and we're gonna lose cut your
losses leave we shouldn't be involved
Chris I want to ask you about
um so I understand that the arguments
that people make for helping out in
Ukraine frequent currently there's
something along the lines of well you
know if you don't stop Putin he's going
to keep going and he's going to take
he's going to try to to bring back the
Soviet Union Etc and those arguments to
me are not compelling at all and that's
just because NATO what's wrong with
waiting
to for NATO to actually get involved
until there's an actual threat to a NATO
country there was a reason why Ukraine
is not in NATO now and this is literally
it if I understand correctly NATO didn't
want Ukraine because they didn't want to
directly have a conflict with Russia and
that's what we're getting at right now
if we if we continue to support Ukraine
at some point there's going to be dead
NATO soldiers and then there's going to
be people talking about Article Five and
and and I don't see the off ramp
at all
right now I don't see how we avoid that
because we keep we keep committing to
indefinite uh support until the you know
until Russia's beaten and we and the
realistic perspective is Russia is only
going to be beaten if they choose to be
because they do have nuclear weapons so
I don't see where the off ramp is
with with with us supporting Ukraine the
way that we are what are your thoughts
on um a NATO president Trump is right
what can't freeload anymore good on NATO
good on NATO for all those years after
World War II where we pay we bankrolled
their security cold War's been over what
30 years
some say it never ended just switch to
China yeah oh yeah good point oh that's
a good one oh we could go someplace on
that one yep talking about the military
industrial complex uh so
the polls when I went over there uh I
was over there a couple yeah six eight
weeks after the war started the polls
went to this University right and uh
gave a lecture to some International
Affairs class it was interesting they
literally the leadership of the
University got a sidebar with me and
said should we evacuate and set up an
alternate University I said why they're
like because we think we're gonna get a
nuclear weapon strikes coming in they
were petrified now your point about uh
you know do you think Putin
you think Putin would make a move on uh
on a NATO country I don't and that's why
I think that's why we shouldn't that's
existential exactly and that's why I
think that as as harsh as this is going
to sound to a lot of people we should
keep our nose out of Ukraine because I
don't see
Putin actually making an attack on a
NATO country because that isn't a that's
that that just I don't see any benefit
for for Putin to do that it's it to
actually
try to engage in a war with NATO if
there's a lack of NATO Unity then I
could see him invading Estonia or Latvia
and then posing the question to the
American public and Europeans are you
guys really willing to fight and die for
Estonia because that's what a lot of
people in the United States would be
asking and if you guys ask me that I I
don't know I would respond do you think
American soldiers should die in Estonia
if Russia invades that's the question
you just nailed it I know you that in
Germany I don't yeah so you know I don't
know if the American public is ready to
answer that question if Russia was
willing to take that Chris what do you
guide me oh no you guys go ahead I I
hear the secretary
I would not die for the Estonian people
at the moment thank you I love you
people I love you and I'm here for you
in my own way I think he's not shooting
people for you uh but I think Putin's D
disincentivize of of attacking NATO
countries because he needs turkey he
does he does it let's be clear he does
not have the ass right now like there's
this there is this great statement that
I heard when we were uh losing in Iraq
uh the second or third time I can't
remember what time it was uh great
Powers should never fight small Wars
because one of two things happens one is
you they win and they look like a
complete bully and everybody gangs up
against him or two you they don't win
and you show your blood in the water
you're feckless everybody goes wow
that's a paper tiger
I don't think Russia they do not have
the combat capability right now to do
anything I mean so why why God damn
nukes though oh so
right so I'm all
I'm all about Strategic Defense
Initiative you know Star Wars like I we
were talking technology earlier
dude I think we have the ability to put
that you know we were talking earlier
about putting the bubble around I think
we can do that so Defense Initiative
just like Star Wars remember everybody
made fun of Reagan like this guy's a
complete lunatic the problem with
defensive bubbles is things that come
straight down uh pierce the bubble or or
a better chance to pierce the bubble
like Hypersonic straight down but
they're right the real issue is Russia
probably as invested in cyber warfare
more than anything else well information
operations too but if they're hot farms
and everything yes but I think the
bigger issue is Russia probably has the
capability of blowing up an oil refinery
in a minute
it's it's the the cyber security is not
impossible
you can it's very easy to attack it's
extremely difficult to defend you have
so many attack vectors throughout the
country
you you won't even it's impossible to to
shore up defenses because you don't know
which of the tens of thousands of
industrial plants to protect and you can
start by trying to protect all of them
update every single one but even when
you do eventually someone will find a
new exploit the military the the the
Russians will every single day be trying
to find a way to break through and they
will find it and then they can do who
knows what what do you think ethically
about a general Armistice with uh the
Russian army like in eastern Ukraine
because what I think is happening is
they want that Black Sea port they want
to be able to ship into the
Mediterranean and sell steel to the
world the United States everybody
everybody and uh that means an alliance
with turkey which means an alliance with
NATO so the the end goal seems very
positive for everyone involved if except
for the fact that the ukrainians would
have to seed the Eastern territory the
Don bass or the southern donbass but do
you think that that's a reasonable
de-escalation tactic you're triggering
me and this is where the American
hypocrisy bothers me that there's this
idea that somehow we can dictate terms
the ukrainians get to decide and the
Russians get to decide we can stop
giving them money and you know what if
we stop giving them money and we stop
giving them stuff they're not going to
stop fighting and it's going to go old
school so that's that's not funny when
they get flattened and there's no one
left to fight you
ukrainians have shown that they the
biggest change I saw from when you were
over there right it used to be about 50
50 split 50 were like let's go Rush away
50 let's go to eat let's go to the West
leaning Western but dude last time over
there man the hatred I'm sure it's like
90 yeah the donbis and all that they're
obviously that that's the trade space we
all know that but my point is we're not
going to get to decide that the
ukrainians get to decide then how do
Wars win or how do Wars end exhaustion
and those two countries don't seem to be
exhausted yet so yeah but Ukraine is
look Russia's got its problems
militaristically but Ukraine's only able
to do anything because of NATO support
if we were not providing them with
weapons and intelligence they would have
been flattened in a week
Russia or even Russia I totally disagree
the way that and that's part of my book
actually is we talked about how we
should need to fight differently when
the Russians came down from the north to
uh try to capture Keith and what did you
have you had like Babushka women out
there you know slapping plastic
explosives on freaking uh you know
Russian tanks you had little hunter
killer teams with their pickup truck and
you know uh and anti-tank guns and stuff
so that that's my point is they're
absolutely capable of Defending
themselves even if we pulled everything
out they'd get a lot worse it's a great
argument for us to pull everything out
and back off and be and and because if
that's the case then I see no reason for
us to be but why why it's not you know
what are we gaining from what do we get
why yeah I want to ask you that like why
would we bail why would we pull out when
we can fix the Russian war machine in a
interminable War what do you mean fix
the Russian war machine they're stuck
right now they can't do anything else so
what what do what do I as a tax paying
American citizen gain from everything
we've done in Ukraine
well I kind of am or Ronald Reagan kind
of conservative who believes in peace
through strength and I don't like
bullies and authoritarian regimes and I
think you I get tired of the cliche I
get tired should we should we get
involved in the China dispute with India
I get tired of that cliche about Munich
and whatever year it was and but I mean
where does it end we have to stand
someplace and these people are willing
to fight and die we're not there's not a
single American Trooper dispute with
Russia well they're authoritarian
totalitarian regime that is going has
designs on conquest and so why aren't we
involved in the China dispute with I
think it's in India right why aren't we
involved with that dispute they're
taking care of themselves so I thought
you said the ukrainians could take care
of themselves yeah they can so why are
we there
why not if all they need some material
and so we've got U.S Personnel
underground we've got Special Forces
operating there no we don't yes we do
and let's move it I'll pull it up right
now
Special Forces have been operating for a
long time the internet is so legit Chris
Chris this was a big time Chris come on
you know that there even if there's no
evidence there you know they're there I
mean you can call the intercept fake
news Well The Binding Administration
Shine the Light on shadowy Special Ops
programs let me uh no that's programming
that's another story that's an ultimate
all right
let me uh the intercept reported this a
while ago
let me uh
there's American volunteers I'm pretty
sure volunteers or volunteers
I I suspect there are small numbers when
I last time I was there I'm telling you
other than at the embassy doing uh
Embassy work there were no uh U.S uh
Special Operations I thought there were
Americans there to help them like train
them when the equipment we're setting
they were in Poland they're military
inspectors at the very least no I agree
I don't like bullies the United States
bullied Iraq and Afghanistan for two
decades so like I feel like now we have
Iraq Russia is going to take eastern
Ukraine China is going to take Taiwan
there every war Monger wins now we're
the three strongest countries on Earth
again can we just be peace peaceful and
calm
Russia by the way Russians consider they
want calm Americans talk about peace and
peace
operations inside Ukraine are being
conducted under a presidential covert
action finding current and former
officials said the finding indicates
that the president has quietly notified
certain Congressional Leaders with the
administration's decision to conduct a
broad program of congression clandestine
operations inside the country one former
Special Forces officer said the budget
amended a pre-existing finding
originally approved during the Obama
Administration that was designed to
counter malign foreign influence
activities a former CIA officer told The
Intercept that Biden's use of
pre-existing finding has frustrated some
intelligence officials who believe that
the U.S involvement in Ukraine conflict
differs so much from the spirit of the
finding that should Merit a new one blah
blah blah blah
this is from October 2022. this was a
big deal Ken clippenstein and James
ryzen reported this for the intercept
and it got syndicated basically
everywhere I think the New York Times
picked it up we have the U.S as active
Personnel in the country the argument is
are they engaged in direct conflict or
are they doing infrastructure Logistics
and support regardless
I have not heard an argument
and it's not been Justified to me why we
are providing weapons funding and
Personnel in any capacity the U.S
provided the weapons and the
intelligence to the ukrainians they used
to destroy the Russian Flagship in the
Black Sea why why are we at war with
Russia they've not given us any real
reason I get it Russia is an adversary
Obama called them a regional power
Russia does deals with other countries
it interferes with us in terms of the
energy uh Market that we're trying to
build with Europe the cutter turkey
pipeline so if the real reason
is that we have engaged in war in
Ukraine because we want cheap energy
into Europe so that Europe can build up
its economy as a means to counteract the
growth of China sure I understand that I
don't see that as a good enough reason
Russia is engaged in legitimate energy
trade we are pissed off about it because
we want Europe to expand and they're our
allies so we decide to support a war
against Bashar al-assad and Russia it
just seems like psychotic world-ending
policy especially we consider that
Russia
they're not going to roll over this
conflict is going to get worse so this
all I I look I can talk about how far
back this goes but as a 36 nearly 37
year old man give me a couple weeks my
birthday's coming up I can talk to you
about the extent to which I entered this
and have vast ignorance of the
long-standing conflict but what we know
is Europe has made the argument or I
should say the European Union argument
is they need a strong economic block
because China is growing too rapidly
they need to be able to counter that
Russia controls a large portion of
energy flowing into Europe and charges
them an arm and a leg
the U.S and European uh uh European
organizations institutions wanted to
build a pipeline through through Syria
through turkey the cutter turkey
pipeline Syria said no because we're in
it for Russia
surprise surprise I'll just leave it at
this the country destabilizes the U.S
provides Military Support to certain
Rebel factions Isis expands rapidly and
then we see the conflict escalating with
Ukraine all of its surrounding energy
you've got the gas prom gas Monopoly
through Ukraine you've got barisma with
Joe Biden all of these things centered
around getting cheap energy to allow
European expansion thus It ultimately
comes down to in my opinion there is a
great global conflict it's never ended
the Cold War turns into something else
but if the argument is Europe needs
cheap energy so we are going to go fight
in Ukraine to cause problems to Russia
so that as the war expands if Russia
does team up with China they'll be
substantially weakened I'm like oh
you're basically saying World War Three
is coming we want it we're involved in
it we're not going to back down okay not
a not a good enough reason for me I'd be
honest uh I'm I'm being told either
trust me when I spend all of your money
more than we've spent anywhere else on
this war in Ukraine
uh and it will probably lead to World
War III I'm being told that's the path
we're going to take and I'm not going to
give you a legitimate justification for
why we're doing it
um my attitude is just okay well then
I'm going to Advocate against it every
step of the way because uh if you can't
justify it the American people should
not be giving you support for it I think
that if it's this old British Empire
tactic of keeping the Germans and
Russians separate if the Germans and
Russians create an alliance you have
like an uh a European Asian superpower
in China Russia India Germany then after
20 years the United States is the
of the realm and we lost the war through
ineptitude inactivity whereas right now
they're trying to prevent this Hitler's
invasion of Poland all over again
they're like we're getting in early
we're not going to let them take France
that's a tough question that the
question being should the U.S dominate
the world
should they a lot well I think it's a
cheap price for Putin's foot soldiers
and China has no limit I think no limit
to their relationship with Russia so
um people are right in saying that it's
a proxy war but it's not a proxy war
between the United States and Russia
it's a proxy war between the United
States and China
um Chris what do you think
wow you just always bring it back in
I'm telling you this guy's doing The
Reeling every day
it's nice looking I think the Chinese
are laughing all the way to the bank
right now and I know this week the whole
story is like the Chinese and the
Russians are combining which is
horrifying yes but 2 500 Mile border
between Russia and China China I think
is probably going I love the fact that
the entire Russian army is committed and
stuck in Ukraine because last time I
checked you guys are experts on this the
Chinese have lots of problems with
natural resources which all are just
north of there I gotta think they're
just sitting there going oh we're taking
the Long View we love the fact that the
Russians are getting bled it's
horrifying if you're a Russian soldier
or a mercenary holy cow that's a bad you
got you drew a bad lot on that one but I
think the Chinese are just absolutely
like we couldn't have asked for a better
setup we've got everybody focused over
here and we could just continue to do
what we need to do and they'll likely I
think move into Taiwan at some point
soon I think that balloon is a literal
trial balloon
the way I describe it is when you're
robbing a liquor store you don't care
the gun you have is illegal because
you're committing a worse crime China I
think is getting ready for action in
Taiwan so they don't care if we're
pissed about a balloon they're they're
preparing for something much worse you
think you think they could take Taiwan
they absolutely could take Taiwan the
question is what losses are they willing
to sustain in doing so yeah what would
Taiwan look like afterwards would it
even be there I think they get ashore
and then they get stuck Chris let me
follow up and ask you so you are acting
Secretary of Defense
um during during the time that was going
to transition which are it's supposedly
the most militarically military
militaristically vulnerable time um for
a nation during the Trump Administration
we were still under the Strategic
ambiguity on whether or not we would
defend uh Taiwan but Joe Biden some
people are calling him a blabbering
idiot when he says this but he takes
takes away strategic ambiguity because
he says that we will defend Taiwan could
you give us some insights on what was
happening under the Trump Administration
how we would have reacted to China
trying to invade Taiwan and what do you
think about Joe Biden
um saying now that we would defend time
we'll remember remember the
international school of uh of
international Affairs has this thing
called The Madman Theory you know they
said Nixon was like he was playing the
madman
like he's unstable well that's actually
a valid uh you know concept for how to
deal with foreign adversaries and of
course they thought the world many
people in the world thought Trump was
using the same thing he's using that
madman Theory the pro so I'd everybody
asks like you know what what would have
happened I don't think they would have
taken a car you tried that balloon that
was a probe of our defenses I'm with you
110 pure and simple uh and I don't think
the thing with the Biden you said it's
strategic ambiguity it's actually more
muddled now because you have the
president of the United States says that
we're going to defend Taiwan and then
you have the secretary of state says oh
whoa no change in policy it and then the
Secretary of Defense says the same thing
so I think that the Chinese are like we
don't know what the hell's going came
from the president's mouth though he
said it three times he was in office for
longer than I've been alive I you know I
think he knows am I naive to take him at
his word when he says that we would
defend Taiwan do you not think China's
taking him out his word I don't I don't
know um I don't think we have enough
insight into what's going on in China to
tell you the truth I was just my point
was uh
they could get ashore but they I I can't
I cannot imagine a scenario where the
Chinese take a crack at Taiwan is Taiwan
just massively defended just entrenched
tunnels and no it's just the Train's so
rough there are only three Beaches they
can land on and then they can get ashore
they can get ashore I'm with you but
then what do you do yeah it's a big
island it's a it's a big piece of land
but I but I that China could take it but
it would be very very expensive and you
don't want to deserve lives and
resources and right and destroying it
what's the point of taking something
that turns into a smoldering Rock they
want its resources they want its IP they
want the the chip manual you don't think
it's just because they they're like this
is part of China and we don't care if
it's partly I think partly there's a lot
of ideology in there because yes that's
where the the that's real China yeah
well that's where the the capital the
capitalist the the
um that's where they escape to when the
CCP took over yeah well this is back in
the late 1800s the Boxer Rebellion I
mean that's where the
drugs talking about the cultural
revolution the Chinese the Republic of
China fled to Taiwan and stayed there
Shanghai Shack right yeah yeah and it
was actually I'm pretty sure that um was
it the UN foreign governments I think
the U.S recognized Taiwan as the real
government of China up until a certain
point I think yeah
Nixon yeah Nixon went over there with
Kissinger and they cut a deal to end
that uh
they yeah like China is now the province
and we cut diplomatic relations and all
that stuff with them awful
and it was before that it was the
question remember to colonize China and
they pushed them off the continent it's
just under the islands that was at the
end of the 1800s but remember the reason
we the uh Nixon Administration cut the
deal is we needed to get out of Vietnam
so there was a point for a quo and they
also were like the Soviets we've got to
counter them by bringing the Chinese out
of the orbit it was like familiar with
that story about China about that's why
Nixon went to China I have to look into
that I think we should just start uh
behaving as though World War III has
already ended and then uh get a
homestead get some goats and chickens
that's why I think about a lion with
Russia not in the sense of a military
line alliance against someone I'm saying
that Wars can end and immediately go
back to normalcy like a white piece can
be declared and economics are
immediately struck back up
infrastructure is rebuilt people they
speak the same language you know like
the Russians and ukrainians are
basically the same people it's like
Canadians and Americans we're all like
it'd be crazy for us to be at odds I
mean they speak a different language
Ukrainian and Russia are not the same
language okay they're the Islamic
languages have an overlap right like uh
Cyrillic alphabet they have the same
alphabet like romance languages can
somewhat understand each other you know
they're Latin root or whatever so
Eastern European languages have a
similar root but I could I could
certainly see the conflict ending and
then it's within a day back to normal
like people do not want to kill each
other it's not like a desire a deep
human desire it's yeah they mostly don't
they mostly don't the the psychological
trauma soldiers develop from having to
kill other people like the story from
Vietnam that the troops were shooting
over the heads of the Viet Cong because
they really just people don't want to
kill each other there's a sad sad
reality of War man there's truth to that
but there's also the the fact that like
atrocities that happen to pows and stuff
like that they happen for a reason and
that's because
the people that that do the capturing
just lost you know their buddies or
whatever to the guys they just captured
when you're standing there looking at a
guy that is on you know the opposing
side and you've got him they surrender
or whatever and you know how your your
your platoon was decimated so one out of
ten dudes is gone you know you lost four
or five guys or whatever in the past in
the past week and you've and one of them
was your friend and whatever you've got
those dudes like at your you know in
your in your power people get real evil
real quick that was that my life
Massacre on Vietnam is an example of
that I think they killed 200 civilians
they went in with like helicopter
gunships and like and there's a captain
that issued the order we're just gonna
torch and kill everyone here and they
murdered and no one got any kind of jail
time for it the one guy the captain got
in trouble but then was pardoned by Nick
Halley Cali was his name he's a
lieutenant Lieutenant Captain Medina you
know we learned this we that's educated
and Terrain into every single soldier
that goes into the army you learn about
that about ethical reasoning and how
this is what happens when you lose when
you lose control and that's like we
talked about accountability and
Leadership that's why leadership is so
critical hey I'll tell you what you
you're pretty amped when you uh grab a
hold when you're you come off the
objective and you've taken some
casualties and you grab a hold of your
targets yeah it gets pretty amped but
you know we take that pretty seriously
sometimes things go wrong uh but man
that we talk we we teach that it's the
lieutenant that gave the order if that's
Cali as the lieutenant yeah and he's the
one that got put on was a death sentence
and then commuted the sentence and then
the captain was life in prison or
something they commuted it Medina
because remember
ultimately if you're a commander if
you're a boss you're responsible for
everything that does and doesn't happen
there were Generals and there were
Colonels involved that did not do the
right thing when they identified that
there had been a mask or they did the
cover-up so it just got
it just got really War's ugly for a lot
of reasons and that's one of them I mean
you've taken prisoners is it can be you
know really really really rough it's
it's friendly fire too it's not talked
about enough it's well yeah 35 of
casualties are friendly fire it's it's
rough I don't know the real numbers but
that's what I've heard dude I think it
was a guy in a hell it was like a
Gunship pilot he sat down yeah and
pointed the guns at the Americans it was
like you are not going to kill these
people do you realize he's he's passed
now he received uh like 30 years after
that because he was ostracized for not
being a team player that helicopter
pilot he was finally awarded for his
heroism that's like that's moral courage
right and he finally was awarded towards
the end of his life this happened in
like the 90 or in the 2000s but you know
uh geez yeah it's tragic but Vietnam is
I'm fortunate to have grown up with a
dad that was in the Navy to avoid
getting into the jungle his cousin I
think it was his his cousin got shot
down in a helicopter are just horror
stories you know and parents with no
legs of my friends that had been in the
jungle
it's really people should should educate
themselves on Vietnam and listen to
stories of Vietnam veterans that there's
videos of them on the Internet telling
for an hour talking about either they
were captured what it was like to be in
a foxhole in the dark for
two weeks you know what's your favorite
movie Let's Go my favorite movie at that
time no Vietnam movie come on Apocalypse
Now has to hold up it's good it's slow
though do you do you think you can make
apocalypse now because I think the
audience would be like this is so boring
well the acting was amazing yeah it was
uh all of those movies have Fortunate
Son in them yeah you have to yeah they
have Forrest Gump is that one I love
forests Forrest Gump's great
does that have fortunate Forrest Gump
that's the one Family Guy made the joke
where uh Quagmire was talking about
being in Vietnam and he was like you
know it was it was horrible the
temperature the people the the conflict
Fortunate Son playing Non-Stop and this
shows them on a boat and it's playing
the smell a lot of the soldiers will say
the one of the biggest things is when
you land you get off the thing it's 104
degrees and it smells it just stinks
they used to say that about the uh
Japanese Islands in World War II just
because of the the Heat and they just
sit there no one's cleaning these bodies
up especially not not during World War
II what other there's platoon apocalypse
right that's the one I was thinking oh
come on Full Metal that's got Fortunate
Son in it too I'm pretty sure right I
think it does I'm I'm sure you're right
Creed's clear water revival but that you
do that no you could do like a thrash
version of it would be awesome you could
do that song as heavy as yeah as a metal
song all right I mean we did Garth
Brooks so what what did you do for Garth
Brooks The Thunder Rolls
I gotta hear that came out great I got a
gold record out of it was nice oh wow
well let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
to support our work we got a new show
it's called the culture war with Tim
pool Friday mornings when we record it
goes up at 1pm and this show exists
because we've had many inquiries for
guests who can't they're not necessarily
news commentary and culture commentary
people but they have interesting stories
and things to talk about so this is more
of just a conversational show we had Ali
London surprisingly knows a whole lot
about modern politics and news so I was
like okay maybe we're wrong about this
guy but we do have uh some upcoming
musical guests who have dealt with the
culture war and uh we'll talk about vax
mandates and things like that coming up
plus uh we got some good guests coming
it's gonna be very different
but good conversation so check out
youtube.com timcast where the show is
now live and we'll have Clips in the
show coming up all throughout the next
week
let's read those super chats sir Elliott
says buck buck for those that are fans
of chicken city
um we've got a bully in the chicken City
and Kim had to treat several of the
chickens today including Roberto Jr who
was uh his leg was was bleeding or
something and Margaret had blood on her
and then she had to clean it and tend to
them a mystery well they people think
they know it
there's a camera on it all the time we
know which chicken is doing it we just
need to like watch the footage and and
then I guess that chicken's gonna get
sent to chicken jail or something
deserve it but yeah all right sideways
2013 says Avid V tuber fan just
correcting from earlier most are mid-20s
range women trying to keep their
identity obscured and just want to be
cute anime girls what's vtube it's when
like it's a twitch streamer who has an
anime character that like moves and
talks yeah
all right here we are soldiers that's
another one I haven't seen that fast
movie yeah pat dry says I'd like to make
sure Ian knows his art of the Raw Deal
performance was pure gold I've watched
it so many times and still laugh love
you Ian oh thanks man if you haven't
seen it seen it it's on youtube.com cast
castle and it's uh Ian the host of the
show Rian with Ian who secretly recorded
Roberto Jr was it yeah on the phone
because of the contract he was offered
offered him 50 million chick coins
kellen's in it as well producer that's
right yeah check it out cast Castle all
right where are we at Raymond g Stanley
Jr says Tim that was that was excellent
today everyone agrees the bestest new
culture War show Ali's story and future
activism will be important who came up
with acceptance turns into a requirement
I dig uh that is just something I said I
said tolerance becomes acceptance and
acceptance returns and turns into
requirement like how uh luxuries like
cell phones at some point turned into a
requirement but uh yes Ali London's
story's crazy he was trans Korean a
transgender Korean woman he's a British
male who was living in this world of all
of this identity stuff and so he started
getting surgery to be a Korean person
because he wanted to be Korean he wanted
to look like a K-pop Star and then
ultimately decided he said this he said
I'm still not happy after getting all
the surgery maybe it is transgender
that's the answer started doing facial
feminization and and moving in that
direction and then finally had a
realization he said how much more
surgery do I have to get and when does
this stop and then stopped and started
reflecting on his life and then he
realized it had to come from within and
this wasn't making him happy it was only
making things worse and then he did a
complete 180 and now he's detransitioned
he's writing a book about it saying
people need to find themselves and not
look for validation from others the
really interesting uh conversation it's
like two hours long check it out
youtube.com timcast or I think it's on
Apple and Spotify the culture War
podcast was that it must have been
pretty motivating I'll watch it but that
was like he went through that whole
process and ended up with like you got
to be yourself yeah and don't don't try
to be something that someone one else
wants you to be I'm is that kind of what
you're saying and he said he regrets
that it took it he got all of this
surgery done that altered himself before
he finally realized it yeah well if
easier regrets man because that story is
going to help a lot of people and
probably keep people from having to go
through what you went through he and the
funny thing is I was like when you were
doing this trans Korean stuff we're like
conservatives attacking you and
threatening he was like No And I was
like you didn't get people insulting you
and he's like not really and then I'm
like when you de-transitioned oh the
left sending death threats and hate
they're trying to get him banned he's
been canceled from shows they're just
trying to destroy his life in Korean I'm
like I'm not surprised you know it's
crazy but uh youtube.com timcast if you
want to watch it I do think it was I I
had a fun time talking to him all right
let's see what we got here sweet pete
says can this recent crazy weather be a
type of intentional malicious weather
Warfare
uh when you were the acting Secretary of
Defense did you get briefed on any kind
of weather weapons that may exist if
only biggest regret Tim you know they
brief you on like nuclear war and
terrorism stuff I should have got the
weather brief and I should have got UFOs
and I missed them both big big fail on
my part uh you know we we do have
weather we have the ability to control
the weather we screwed it up we did it
in Vietnam what did they do uh see the
clouds silver silver eyes to make Iran
yeah we were going in they were doing
that in North Vietnam to flood the
rivers the problem was there was an Amer
there was a POW Camp called Sante
s-o-n-t-a-y that we did the most bold
Commando raid in like the history of the
world they flew up in there and they
landed and the The Prisoner War Camp was
on this river that had due to the fact
that we were messing with the weather
the River overflowed so they moved the
prisoners a couple days prior and wow
it's a Silverado silver iodide
yeah uh it's crystallized silver iodide
and it causes water particles to start
condensing but they also have in the
past probably longer than a decade but a
decade ago or so it was reported Germany
was using infrared lasers I was
wondering about that yeah no to to uh
create rain I think you can make people
make lightning out of it like you would
force would it heat like the water
molecules or something something like
that I don't know they found a way to
condense okay you know so makes sense
yeah in Dubai yeah they're like drones I
think that's what you're talking about
Ian with like they're using heat or
electricity of some kind I heard it was
silver I died but it could be newer Tech
as well yeah that was pretty recent
wrath says Tim if you start a new
channel for your Poker podcast idea you
should name it the pool table for all
your tabletop needs I think we wanted
we're gonna call it poker with the boys
what do you guys think I don't know so
it wasn't my idea someone else suggested
that we do a Sunday night hangout live
stream where we just get a bunch of
dudes who play poker and then it's
mostly just a conversation hangout with
poker as a backdrop and I was talking to
Clint from liberty lockdown he was
actually a pro poker player and I was
like I certainly wouldn't be the guy for
it it's got to be him or someone but
then we would all hang out and it would
just be fun because we'd have
conversations similar to this but it
would be sillier there'd be booze and
chips and whatever and people are having
nachos and getting drunk and then you
know calling Bluffs or whatever I think
it'd be fun fun show someone else
pointed it out to me I can't remember it
might have been Matt Brainerd maybe I'm
not sure hey speaking of control the
weather I saw this article high-powered
lasers can be used to steer lightning
strikes do you know what a laser induced
plasma channel is Yes an electro laser
that is a high power what is it
plasmatic hydrogen just focused in a
beam they use infrared lasers to ionize
the air creating a path for electricity
to travel down
so the energized or whatever particles
in the air the electricity can travel
through it so it creates a path of least
resistance and you can look this up
um it was um was it called Picatinny or
whatever Piccadilly I don't know some
Air Force Base which one is it they were
experimenting with laser-induced plasma
Channel weapons the idea was you pick a
Tenny Picatinny isn't it yeah you mount
a gigantic machine that fires an
infrared laser uh for a Split Second
and then the the electrode is charged
already so as soon as the laser fires
the electricity travels straight down
the path and hits whatever so they were
like shooting cars with bolts of
lightning and ultimately they were like
it's cumbersome inconvenient and energy
exhaustive there's no reason to do it
but it's awesome but it's so cool it's
like shooting imagine if you had like a
backpack with a battery and you could
pull a trigger and blast lightning at
somebody I'm seeing Ghostbusters right
now as soon as you said that with the
thing in the back though did you was I
the only one no I was thinking it was
robot there's a you're shooting at a
bunch of different directions at once
you could look up videos on YouTube
they're small versions one is a guy put
it in his door creating a quote-unquote
force field where you can see the arcs
of lightning going
you know all over where the
laser-induced plasma channel is
happening what's the difference between
that like a rail gun is that like rail
guns use an electromagnetic in sequence
to project a piece of metal uh okay yeah
okay railguns are crazy yeah full auto
railgun just it's like a it's
electromatic pulse so I want to launch
spacecraft with rail on railgun type
well actually there I was reading about
that and ultimately I think they decided
for space package delivery they're going
to use high speed centrifuges yeah
that's smart there was a discussion I
was reading about how they did want to
use railguns use an electromagnetic
railgun to do it and then they
ultimately decided just to swing it have
you seen any videos on that their videos
they're doing it yeah they're doing it
there's a company doing it I forgot the
name of it it's legit spinning it so
fast and then just sending it down a
tube launching into space I'll send you
I'll send it here it is uh the startup
wants to throw satellites in door with a
giant centrifuge yeah yeah spin launches
way less energy required you don't need
all that fuel and yeah yeah and it goes
It goes uh supersonic so that's the one
thing is like they have to do this in
the middle of the desert because you get
a Sonic Boom coming out wow is that
crazy yeah man imagine working there
I I imagine that that something like
this would be
would be at a Spaceport right I think
that's where they want to put it like
yeah or something yeah put it put it
like I mean because Rockets are are you
know the the sound of rockets like you
have to be really far away because
they're massive and blah blah so I
imagine if you have to worry about you
know the sound levels of Spaceport would
make sense for this stuff to to to be
you know you can't believe that I'm
talking about Spaceport let's read some
more you got a song out of that you're I
know you're thinking about it Martin
small says Chris it's great to see you
on IRL you are the best leader I had in
my 21-year career strength and honor
holy cow that's humbling that's when I
start getting weepy man what was your
role
a couple of Commander what particular
Rank and command capped uh a Special
Forces Green Beret so what was that came
out uh
yeah that's what I did I was just green
break Captain major like you start you
have 12 men and then you go to like 60
and then you go to 400 and then I got
out would you spend time in the field
like for weeks at a time yeah man that's
that's it baby that's it we got uh
Angela Richter in the member chat saying
ha I live a few miles from SpaceX and my
house is being shaken apart as I watch
this oh no it's so cool
I hope your house stays together but man
yeah what a way to lose the property
anyways has anybody gone down and see us
has anybody seen a space launch down
there I'm desperate to do that that's
bucket list yeah you know what I really
want I want to be flying I saw a video
of this and I want to be in person be
flying through the air in an airplane
when I'm watching a rocket launch or
better the the boosters land yeah that
would be super cool be in an airplane
and watch boosters land that would be
super awesome all right the Fizz says
I'm a board member for a non-profit for
Disaster Response I know you guys are
particular with sponsorships and
shutouts where can you send to you guys
and where can I send you guys an email
about our organization to see if we
could work together I think on this
YouTube channel in the about section
there should be an email address for
sponsorships but we are very particular
I just I prefer to keep sponsorships to
a very to a very very minimum
I mean look
all of these companies they come to me
and they want to sign us for some reason
or another and the fine print in the
contracts is always if you read six ads
per episode you'll make 50 million
dollars a year and I'm like I don't want
to read six ads per episode I'd rather
just not have that although part of me
is kind of like man what could you do
with all that money you could hire a
bunch of people you could build a bunch
of stuff but I just I can't do it I'm
not going to do it you could hire
someone the Micro Machines man speaker
the guy that talks really fast and have
him do the read so you can do that I
mean I could talk pretty fast if I had
to but um you know it's a really
interesting thought Phil before we
finish that why don't you guys head over
to timcast.com and become a member no
I'm not a fan of uh podcasts that that
do that it's kind of off-putting you're
watching an interview and there's some
guy saying like
when I was there
The Killing Fields
children that I saw that's really
interesting before we move on head over
to largediapers.com a sponsor for
today's show and you'll get 20 off and
I'm just like well then you always have
to enter the code right there's always
some special code that that's so they
know if the ads working so whenever they
say yeah so the reason ads are always
like you'll get 10 off if you use promo
code Tim it's actually so that they can
look in their internals and be like hey
look we got a thousand new customers who
use Tim the Tim ads are working buy more
of them so you're not going to do it
we do some ads sometimes YouTube has
programmatic ads but for the most part I
think memberships at timcast.com are the
principal way to run the business it's
kind of like I would rather have
customers as opposed to like if you're
if you're doing sponsorships the
sponsors are your customers and the spot
and your customers expect a good product
and then you end up with I don't like
that you said that thing about that
stuff and you're like well I'm going to
keep saying it like well I'm not going
to be a customer of yours and if you
rely on that then you're beholden to
companies that want to sell diapers or
whatever as opposed to the people who
watch your show if you do it as
memberships then we're beholden to the
people who are paying our memberships
and not corporations who sell products
not that I have a problem with that I
mean if your corporation sells products
we have some sponsors ultimately I
decided we'll sponsor ourselves so we're
launching a coffee brand and we're
probably going to do some kind of
supplements or something
and then just basically be our own
sponsors so that way we can't cancel
ourselves and we are still more beholden
to our audience who are our customers
it's like social media you're not the
customer for Twitter you're the product
the customer is the advertiser yeah I
don't want to run a business like that
I'd rather have the people listening to
the show be the customers that we're
accountable to and not it's great yeah
I'm motivated what's the name of the
coffee can you tell us yet not yet
um it's delayed but I think it should be
done in a couple weeks it was supposed
to be like December they we call the
company and they're like we can have
everything ready in a week and I'm like
awesome and they're like yep six weeks
and I was like okay Supply Chain man
it's a very long that's true and we've
got uh like 80 percent of the new studio
done but there's no internet because uh
I think it's Comcast they're like we
don't have the materials to build sorry
have a nice day call must do startling
we have starlink it's not strong enough
oh really the upload right for starlink
I think is like eight megabits it's
impractical so it's like old school like
dial-up modem type oh
old school cable you know when you're
getting like a megabit and you were
excited I'm getting eight megabits up
it's like okay I can do a 480 live
stream we can upload video files it'll
take 20 minutes you know right now we've
got we've got greater than gigabit
so it's unfortunate but we're building
infrastructure in a semi-rural area uh
mostly rural area and that means they've
got to lay down the lines lay down the
fiber and they don't have the materials
to actually build it they said sorry we
don't have it when we get it we'll let
you know
yeah I don't know maybe if I if I speak
on a show like this and say like hey
Comcast we need to internet or new
headquarters someone listening might
know somebody and be like can we divert
resources and make this happen or
something Twitter might be your best bet
I feel like the companies love Twitter
now it took like four months to get
internet here it was crazy because they
had to actually dig like hang lines and
like Berry line and actually
for Miles like like two miles up the
road laid down the fiber lines and bring
it to the house it's crazy it's a lot of
work to do it's very expensive it's
ridiculously expensive I did the same
thing in my place had to drive put in
put in a line from the road all the way
up a mile but when you're when you're in
a residential area or an urban area that
already has back hall and and lines in
the ground 100 bucks a month for gigabit
when you're in a rural area it's
thousands of dollars a month for the
same internet and then when they install
it they installed it wrong and they gave
us the wrong box so it had it at an
optical Port and like an ethernet port
and they gave us the wrong Port then we
tried to buy converters and we were like
this is insane and then they had to come
out reconfigure like swap out or
something it isn't crazy
all right what do we got here
Philip Reed says if Ian ever leaves
Tim's gonna hang up a sign that says
long hair freaky people need not apply
that's actually a good idea to hang up
behind Ian as right now yeah
Andrew Puckett says Ian's the type of
guy who wants to hug in combat
I I think so I mean
I don't I don't I don't want to do that
Kenneth Hart says guys what happened
with Tim and Ian in the last three days
episodes have been fire the energy is
better the flow is better and you seem
to be having more fun everyone seems to
be having fun you know I am having fun
you know once we started working
throughout Congress
beyond the drugs I I credit Congress
spending time at Congress has given me a
new lease on life man I I have Hope and
Faith in the system seeing the amount of
work that they are willing to put in
like Lauren bobert Works 28 days a month
she goes she spends four days a month at
home because she's willing to sacrifice
and spend that much time her family her
kids are there in the in there with her
like the the whole family the sacrifice
there it's amazing it's inspiration I
have never heard of a person talk about
Congress
once you get inside and you see the
camaraderie and the willingness we're
talking about just the freedom caucus
and like Matt Gates yeah it's like eight
people yeah I love you send me to
Congress I'm not your buddy guy says Tim
you've got white stuff above your left
lip I I am uh outraged at the body
shaming that has been going on in chat
from the people who are saying that
there is something white in my mustache
it is the graying of my beard it is it
is turning gray I have gray hairs and
y'all are are shaming me and saying I
have boogers and don't you ever stop to
think about what other people feel when
you're shaming no so um this is why guys
get the Just For Men stuff and color
their beard I always thought it was
silly because I'm like who cares you go
Greg you go gray I don't care but then
someone pointed out to me they were like
the problem is people keep going oh
you've got something and you're like no
it's just turning white and they're like
oh and you you say that 10 times a day
you're like I'm just gonna put this
stuff in to make or pluck the hair or
something but when it's getting whiter
then you've got a you know more more
green vegetables should darken the hair
less salt more green veg all that I've
gone through phases where I'll get white
and really dark and another thing that
works really well is adrenochrome I hear
the oxidized blood of uh no no
what was that adrenaline oxidized
adrenaline that's what I meant no it
actually I'm pretty sure it's poison and
that's a that's you know people actually
eat that stuff I ask you because I think
it's a fence
I don't think it's real and I was
reading about it and it's it's poisonous
like you can't ingest it you know
adrenochrome anyway it's funny
all right all right where are we at
where are we at John Kirsten says Ian we
cannot use conventional tactics against
Guerrilla tactics use their Rules for
Radicals back against them and fight
their gorilla war with their own gorilla
tactics morality is on our side I agree
with that but I think you're complaining
the culture War which isn't actually a
war that's an important thing to
remember excuse me it's not a real war
yes it is uh it's a cold Civil War I
don't think you call that War I think
that's softening the term it's Google
the definition of war and then let's see
if we agree or disagree let's see what
Carlos Carl Von clauswits
and while you're doing that Karen gaming
news says where's Mr bocus Tim probably
peeing on the floor somewhere he's
sleeping he's sleeping downstairs right
now I haven't brought him in here or is
the extenuation of politics by other
means go ahead interesting I think
that's cause wits a state of open armed
often prolonged conflict carried on
between nation states or parties so open
but there's more there's more than just
the one definition the period of such
conflict so like that that was the war
are and then the techniques and
procedures of War I don't know why
you're using the word and the definition
that makes no sense so I like your
definition Chris I'm pulling it up a
sustained effort to deal with or end a
particular unpleasant or undesirable
situation or condition
that's pretty vague right because
because the issue is
words are defined by how they're used
and when we when we say Cold War
we don't go well the dictionary says
that war is armed conflict therefore the
Cold War never happened it was more of
the cold political dispute between
nations it's like okay like we call it a
cold war because because there were
nuclear arms pointed at each other if
there wasn't weapons involved we
wouldn't influence operations and spying
and stuff so when you have like Aaron
Danielson getting shot twice in the
chest and killed by a guy with us with a
communist tattoo on his neck I'd argue
we are in the we are in a in a hot
conflict it's just not to the point
where the the what we're dealing with is
the weaponization of government against
the political enemies uh January 6 type
stuff we're looking at pro-lifers
getting arrested we're looking at
leftists getting a free pass like there
is a cold Civil War happening and it was
a Yale Professor five years ago who said
it so if you don't want to take his word
for it totally fine but you have to
acknowledge that we've seen violence
death conflict all under the guise of of
political tribalism and extremism so is
it a hot civil war with marching nation
states against each other no but it is a
cold Civil War I think it's a fair fair
Sun Tzu wrote that the ultimate goal of
warfare is to win without fighting oh I
love that one there you go Tim can I
give myself a shout out yeah all right
so you guys spend a lot of money to
train and educate me when I was a
military officer and it worked because I
was right with the Carl Von Claus with
quote war is the continuation of
politics by other means probably the
only thing I learned think it's stuck I
don't know what it means that's a good
definition yeah
which kind of ties into what you're
saying actually in a weird sort of way
affecting policy through means other
than your standard political process
that's bad because you could have
affecting policy through other means
that isn't War like economically bribery
bribery is not warfare that's War that's
economic Warfare It's softening the term
of economic Warfare is war bro sanctions
are are a catalysts of war and a huge
exactly they're Catalyst and a huge
component of War leads are an act of War
blockade blockades they're an act of War
no-fly zones a lot of these those are
all threats of force of Weaponry a
blockade yeah there's something cutting
all up and what do you think sanctions
are do you think we just say don't you
do this
no it's because we're saying we will
lock people up and put them in boxes at
gunpoint
everything is under the under the threat
of force we if we had libraries not
bribery's you just
yeah so robbing your political opponents
isn't War but it's a means other than
you know I disagree I think I think it
it depends on the the circumstance for
which you are bribing the person
obviously if you're like hey I want to
build I want to get an easement on my
land push through the the the the
permits okay sure but if it's like I
want to ban this group of people from
being able to talk here's a bunch of
money
don't let them talk yeah that's that's
War
uh every everything in government is
backed by the Monopoly on violence
that's how government functions are we
we're talking about we're talking about
literal War like the definition of War
like Congress is the only body able to
declare war we haven't been at War since
with me bro so Vietnam was a war it was
Vietnam no one declared the Cold War so
it never happened right it wasn't a war
the Cold War never happened to Clarence
step in front say legally the Cold War
was a war you'd be wrong
and no one's talking about legally we're
talking about human ideas and
understanding and often in an attempt to
win arguments you change definitions of
words well that's that's a disingenuous
way to win an argument that's what you
do I agree you are just you call it the
culture or tongue-in-cheek it's not
because it's an actual War I literally
said it is a cold Civil War people have
been shot and killed there are people
hacking sending death threats there's
Banks shutting down people's uh finances
like this is all an attempt to destroy
people's lives cause them physical
economic a harm in an effort to win a
political battle I feel like you could
move into someone's City and they'll be
like he's declaring war on us by by
taking our goods and services and land
from us even though you just did it
totally on the board the gentrification
has been called War yeah gentrification
is war now it depends so so so like it's
almost like you live in a black and
white world where things are binary well
when people use words improperly I get a
little upset but you use words
improperly all the time
all the time no I did it earlier well
mean actually no therefore the whole
part of that exchange was the the you
are most famous for making semantic
arguments to try and prove a point that
doesn't make sense like this is what
people complain about I don't care about
people list on the internet I'm telling
you that everyone is desperately trying
to tell you use semantic arguments all
the time that's true you use the term
all the time as if it's like a cudgel
and you're wrong I don't do that often
we were on stage at long shots and we
were talking about the great thing like
the the great things you bring up on the
show and then I said but not the
semantic arguments and everyone started
cheering and clapping in the audience
you created that meme no no I didn't yes
I am simply responding to what people
are literally saying in the chat I don't
make it up you were the one that said
semantics like while we were at the old
office and then other people started
carrying it being mean in math means the
average so if you're being mean to
someone you're bringing them to the
average like no that's that's it that's
a that's that's not a it's a homonym not
a synonym that there's no relation to
those words
and that's what you did anyway let's
read some more Super chats all right all
right all right what do we got
uh let's see God gave rock and roll to
you says ask him oh wait I'm sorry the
National Guard is for riots I want our
military to handle the invasion at the
southern border
yes yeah yes
all right essay federally says Chris is
saying what I tried selling to my
recruiters 20 years ago and I was and
was told I watched too many movies I'm
going to keep up with what he's he's
doing for sure
yeah
yeah they're like get a big Jet and fly
the jet around and it's like uh some
dude's gonna pop out of the bushes with
a remote control car with a bomb strap
to it and he's gonna drive it into your
tent and you're gonna be like what's
that thing
is what's going on in the southern
border war is it an invasion yes I think
it's a Nash I think it's the purpose of
our military
when you have people marching with flags
of their home country into your country
like I don't understand why that's not
an invasion it's like literally people
waving a flag of another country
marching into yours like if if this was
1500s France and a bunch of British
subjects with British flags marched into
France and then stuck the flag in the
ground said This Land Is Ours now and
we're gonna live and work here they'd be
like okay these British people are
invading France
you don't have to start shooting each
other with bows and arrows or whatever
it's like it happened
all right where are we at let's grab a
couple more as we wrap up Brandon says
damn I love this show Ian is the man
thanks Dan but that was an old super
chat if he turned the last five minutes
and too honest too honest just take the
take the winner
uh there's a bunch of redacted super
chats people are rescinding them maybe
it's because they were saying mean
things but then they said yes mean
things about Ian but then decided they
shouldn't they realized they didn't want
to bring you into average
all right let's let's uh here we go
Steven says all the fiber optic cable in
the eastern U.S is getting buried here
in Franklin North North Carolina well I
need it
I am I am outraged all right everybody
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
and head over to youtube.com timcast and
check out the first episode of the
culture war with Tim pool featuring Ali
London as our first guest a man who is
transitioning to be a Korean woman and
is now detransitioned and wrote a book
about it and is speaking out against
what they're doing to people and kids
and actually a motivational section in
his book about how to overcome these
identity issues and and find yourself
it's really interesting stuff we got uh
that's going to be once a week the
episodes will go up on Friday
Fred is not a good day to ever publish
anything but it is what it is and I
assume people can watch the episodes
throughout the week if they want to
we'll have Clips up throughout the week
as well and we're gonna have more guests
from the cultural spaces talking about
life and what's going on we've got a
real we've got really great guests
coming up the next three guests are
going to be incredible so check that out
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
Chris do you want to shout anything out
modern Town Square is what you're doing
this is really important thanks for
having me on give me a chance to laugh
but also try to answer some questions
probably failed in most cases but thanks
which what you guys are doing it's
really important for our country right
on could you tell us more about your
book too I'm so bad at my pitch and the
Publisher's like you got to pitch your
book all the time you can hold it up too
hey this thing you allow so everybody
will could all my buddies critique my
book like I didn't like you know this
part I'm like did you laugh like I did
laugh I'm like my mission is complete
but this talks about you know uh some
good stories but at the end of the day
it's about accountability it's about
moving forward with our country and it's
also about you know those that serve and
those they serve we got to do better
bringing that together back to our point
because what you brought up civilian
oversight is essential to our country
and I just kind of behind the scenes uh
you know I'm talking too much I know you
know hey I know we got to get off like
I should never have had this job I'm a
kid from Iowa it only happens in America
you know I wasn't one of these uh I was
just a guy who started out in the field
and was fortunate enough to lead our our
men and women uh our Armed Forces we're
really fortunate in this country and I
got great hope absolutely I got great
hope I'm sorry I know you guys get a
little down in the mouth I listen you're
like well it's the end of the world I'm
like man we got you go out in America
you know it you see it out there those
people it may be a dramatic
transformation but I said the other day
humans have overcome every single
challenge set before them thus far and I
don't think we're the exception where
it's all going to fall apart I think
things could get bad but uh we'll figure
it out yep yeah Chris thank you so much
for coming on I'm going to check out
your book uh thanks for tuning in
everybody I am a lot of Yahoo I report
for timcast news you can find me on
Twitter a lot of Yahoo Instagram barely
informed with a lot and uh that's it
thank you and the leader of the Bolton
Bros leader of the Bolton Bros
um one day we're gonna have a must
Stash's only episode hopefully yeah I'll
tell you about next time ahead of time
Chris we sure would have known I am Phil
Labonte uh lead vocalist for All That
Remains uh uh anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary you can check me
out on Twitter Phil that remains on
Instagram uh Philip remains official
I'm Ian Crossland at Ian crossland.net I
got a few speaking engagements coming up
one of which will be on May 13th in
Oakland California called the it's part
of the take Human Action tour.com uh
speaking tour we're going to be with the
mises caucus speaking so that's take
human actiontour.com you can get tickets
there awesome Chris I'm really looking
forward to working with you in the
future man that was some real pleasure I
didn't let you guys down like content
was bad like oh that was dude we barely
as long as you don't storm out after a
half an hour we're good just thanks for
everything you've done obviously and and
being able to talk about it publicly so
easily it's really cool and you were
saying we controlled the weather I was
thinking like who is we as well
who is that it's they before we go I'd
like to introduce Kellen yes um yeah
Fridays are always fun thanks a bunch uh
it's great conversation you're a very
funny guy
um hey tomorrow uh rally for Ukraine I
know all of Tim cast viewers are going
to be there bright and early but no uh
lad and I will be down there in DC
interviewing people about the Ukraine
war
um is that what it's called rally for
Ukraine it's the one year anniversary of
uh since Russia invaded uh the territory
so check uh yeah so check that out and
then also again check out the cultural
war with Tim Poole it's a great new show
I listened to it it was awesome you guys
can follow me at Kellen PDL on Twitter
thanks guys thanks for hanging out
everybody and we will see you all with
Clips throughout the weekend and then
we'll be back on Monday